Guys, when's the last quickie you had? Sean? Well, probably yesterday. What do you mean by quickie? Well, that's... What do you mean by probably yesterday? Welcome to Smartless. Lattice. Smart. Lattice.
大家，你们上次速战速决是什么时候？肖恩？嗯，大概昨天吧。你说的速战速决是什么意思？嗯，那是……你说的“大概昨天”是什么意思？欢迎来到 Smartless。Lattice。Smart。Lattice。
Smart. Lattice. JB, JB, let's just get into your hairs midway short. Yeah, yeah. I know, look at that. And tomorrow morning the rest of this garbage comes off and I'll just be into stubble and then I'll be into a mullet. And you already cut a little bit of your hair a little bit.
Smart。Lattice。JB，JB，我们直接聊聊你那半长不短的头发吧。对，对。我懂，你看那个。然后明天早上剩下的这些垃圾就全剃了，我就留点胡茬，接着我就要留鲻鱼头了。你其实已经把头发剪短了一点点。
Yeah, so I'm gonna keep the party in the back and pull in some business on the sides and the top. And that'll work for two days. And then we go backwards 20 years. So I'll go back into like your level, your short hair, Sean, and clean shaven. Like a Michael Bluth, you're gonna go back to a Michael. I'll go back to a Michael Bluth or a Marty Bird
对，所以我打算保持后脑勺的朋克发型，两边和头顶走商务路线。这造型能撑两天。然后我们就时光倒流20年。所以我会回到你那个水平，你那种短发，肖恩，而且刮得干干净净。就像迈克·布鲁斯一样，你要回到迈克……我会回到迈克·布鲁斯或者马蒂·伯德
or really every other part I've ever played in my life. How dare you, how dare you. Yeah, the acting stretches have not been significant in my career. Not true. Will you be sad to see the change go? Yeah, a little bit, but I gotta tell you, I don't know how women do it with the long hair and the showering, you know, like,
或者实际上是我这辈子演过的所有其他角色。你敢，你怎么敢。对，我演艺生涯中的戏路跨度真的一点都不大。才怪。看到这个改变消失，你会难过吗？对，有一点，但我必须得告诉你，我真不知道女人是怎么顶着长发还洗头的，你知道的，就像，
it's always tangled in your face, and it takes you 20 minutes to wash your hair. It's just a nightmare. It's been coming up on a year since you've been growing that hair out and stuff. I mean, this is like a- Longer than a year. Yeah, so this is a big, this is gonna be a big departure.
总是纠缠在你的脸上一团糟，洗个头发还得花上20分钟。简直就是一场噩梦。你留长发这事，差不多有一年了吧？我是说，这就像是一个——比一年还久。对，所以这是一个巨大的，这将会是一个巨大的改变。
Yeah, I can't wait. My daughters are excited to be done with my nonsense. My wife is not happy about it. So I saw your wife last night. Yeah, that's what I heard. Yeah, and then she said to me, she's like, I like it, because my hair's getting a little bit longer than I usually have it.
对，我等不及了。我女儿们很高兴终于不用再忍受我的胡闹了。我妻子对此很不高兴。所以我昨晚见到你太太了。对，我也听说了。对，然后她对我说，她挺喜欢的，因为我的头发比我平时留的要长了一点。
Yeah, it's very long now. And she goes, I like it that way, and then our friend goes, no, it's too long. It's, yeah, I don't like it like that. And then also proceeded to tell me that I was a little overweight. Oh, this is another guest at the party? Yeah, so this is the host.
对，现在真的很长了。然后她说，我挺喜欢这样的，然后我们的朋友说，不，太长了。这，对，我不喜欢这样。然后接着还告诉我，我稍微有点超重。哦，这也是派对上的另一个客人吗？对，所以这是主人。
And I'm like, okay, well, that feels great. I think you look beautiful. Yeah. You actually look a little thin to me. That's what I said. Yeah, I'd like to fatten him up a little bit. You look beautiful. You actually look a little thin to me. That's what I said. I'd like to fatten him up a little bit. You look thinner. Sorry, I don't mean to talk to you about,
然后我说，好吧，那感觉真棒。我觉得你看起来很漂亮。对。其实我觉得你有点瘦。我是这么说的。对，我想把他喂胖一点点。你看起来很漂亮。其实我觉得你有点瘦。我是这么说的。我想把他喂胖一点点。你看起来更瘦了。抱歉，我不是故意跟你谈论……
I just don't like to do some sort of like, concubine that's just coming. Can you hold please? I'd like to plump you up a little bit before our session. I love. Sean, how are you feeling? You're still in New York. we still haven't seen each other. I know, but.
我只是不想搞得像个刚来的小妾一样。请等一下好吗？在我们的访谈开始之前，我想把你喂胖一点。我喜欢。肖恩，你感觉怎么样？你还在纽约。我们还是没见面。我知道，但……
It's as if we don't like each other. But if, when you're done with your show. This is my plan, I was gonna say this, but I'll say this. I was gonna say, please come over. Thursday night, let's do it, because I'm getting in Wednesday, let's do a Thursday night dinner, either at Seanie at your apartment or somewhere.
搞得好像我们互相嫌弃似的。但是如果，等你节目结束之后。这是我的计划，我本来想说的，但我现在就说吧。我本想说，请过来吧。周四晚上，我们聚聚吧，因为我周三到，让我们在周四晚上吃个晚饭，要么在肖恩你公寓，要么在别的地方。
That would be great. Yeah, great, because I'm furious that I have now, you know, I'm finishing on Wednesday after seven or eight months on this thing. Well, and not including the prep, a month of prep. Well, no, that includes it. And my wife, because she's smarter and kinder about our friends than I am,
那太棒了。对，太棒了，因为我很生气，你知道的，我周三终于要结束这玩意儿了，在这上面耗了七八个月。嗯，还不包括前期筹备，一个月的筹备。噢，不，那包括在内了。而我的妻子，因为她对我们的朋友比我更聪明、更善良，
has forced me to not come home after eight months of being away and stay an extra five days to go see our friend who's opening in a new play. And so I have to sit here and just kill five days of my life waiting for this. But that's when you come over and we'll take care of you. But I mean, I don't think our friend would care
强迫我在离开八个月后不要直接回家，而是多留五天去看我们那位在排新戏的朋友。所以我只能坐在这里，白白浪费生命中的五天来等这个。但那就是你过来的时候，我们会照顾你的。但我的意思是，我觉得我们的朋友才不在乎
if I come see it like in a month or in two months. Yeah. Right? Is opening night that big of a deal? No, but yeah, it's nice. We're all gonna go. It's gonna be nice. You're doing it for somebody else. Yeah.
我是一个月还是两个月后来看呢。对吧？首演之夜有那么重要吗？不，但是，对，挺好的。我们都会去的。会挺不错的。你是为了别人才去的。对。
But why didn't we all do it later? What do you think your face is doing right now? It probably looks pretty pissed off. That's just gravity. Yeah, but it's the good, nice thing to do. We're gonna have dinner, the three of us, then we're gonna do Jack, JB, we already talked about it this weekend.
但我们为什么不把时间都约在晚一点呢？你觉得你现在脸上在做什么表情？大概看起来挺生气的吧。那只是重力作用。对，但这是件好事，也是该做的事。我们三个先吃晚饭，然后我们要去见杰克，JB，我们这周末已经聊过了。
So you're gonna kill some time for me. You're not gonna be stuck out on Long Island, you're gonna stay here in the city? No, I'm not coming, I'm not gonna go to Long Island. I'm just gonna be in the city the whole time. Oh, great. Yeah. All right, so then I've got you until the kids
所以你要帮我打发点时间。你不会被困在长岛，你会留在城里吗？不，我不去，我不去长岛。我整个过程都会呆在城里。哦，太好了。对。好吧，那我就能一直“拥有”你，直到周五孩子们
and the wife get here on Friday. Exactly right. And Sean is still in town. Yeah. And I'm still not seeing him. We worked it out. We worked this out. We have it all laid out for you when you come over.
和妻子过来。完全正确。而且肖恩还在城里。对。而我还是没见到他。我们已经商量好了。我们把这事都安排好了。等你过来的时候，我们都给你规划好了。
If you're listening out there and you wanna grab a lunch or something, just let us know. I was walking down the street the other day and this girl had her earbuds in and she goes, Oh my God, Sean Hayes. I go, yeah, she goes, you're really in New York just like you said you were on the podcast.
如果你正在收听节目，想顺便吃个午饭什么的，尽管告诉我们。我前几天走在街上，这个女孩戴着耳机，然后她说：“噢天哪，肖恩·海斯。”我说：“对呀。”她说：“你真的在纽约，就像你在播客里说的那样。”
I mean. I don't make it up. Now, all right, here comes a guest. It's been 50, no, 24 minutes this guest has been waiting with my bad technological problems. All right. Today, for your listening pleasure, I have brought to you an actor, a writer, a producer,
我是说。我才不会瞎编呢。好了，好吧，客人来了。这位客人因为我糟糕的技术问题，已经等了50分钟……不对，24分钟了。好的。今天，为了满足大家的耳福，我给你们请来了一位身兼数职的嘉宾：演员、作家、制片人、
an academic, an activist, and a cellist, all in one. A cellist? A cellist, all in one. A cellist. A cellist, yeah. Wow. For me, his ability to deliver social, political, and religious commentary, wrapped up in side-splitting comedy, is completely unmatched, making him one of the most effective and valuable satirists we have in this world.
学者、活动家和大提琴家，集于一身。大提琴家？大提琴家，全才。大提琴家。大提琴家，对。哇。对我而言，他传递社会、政治和宗教评论的能力，完美包裹在令人捧腹大笑的喜剧中，简直是无可匹敌，这使他成为当今世上最有效、最宝贵的讽刺作家之一。
He starred in multiple movies, both comedic and dramatic, worked with some of our fanciest directors, been nominated, won multiple awards, and he is my absolute favorite person to see at a party. Guys, the sneaky handsome, devastatingly funny, Cambridge smart, yet always cheeky, Sasha Baron Cohen. Oh, for God's sake, look at him go!
他主演了多部电影，既有喜剧也有剧情片，与我们最顶级的导演合作过，获得过提名，赢得过多个奖项，而且他绝对是我在派对上最想见到的人。伙计们，这位低调帅气、风趣绝伦、拥有剑桥智商却又总是调皮捣蛋的萨莎·拜伦·科恩。噢，天哪，快看他出场！
Sasha, I'm so sorry for the delay. No, don't worry. I mean, a man of your... I'm not, now I don't feel so bad knowing it's Sasha. Now that it's Sasha, it's okay. Will, let me butter him up and then you take him down. Okay, thank you. It's ridiculous that I've left somebody of your stature
萨莎，对于耽误了这么久，我深感抱歉。不，别担心。我是说，像你这样身份的人……我不，现在知道是萨莎，我心里好受多了。既然是萨莎，那就没问题了。威廉，让我先拍拍他的马屁，然后你再打击他。好的，谢谢。我让像你这样地位的人
waiting this long, I apologize. Come, come. Please. It's an honor. It's an honor to be 114th. Yes. I'm very much. You're deep.
等了这么久，实在是太荒谬了，我道歉。来，来。请。这是我的荣幸。能排在第114位是我的荣幸。是的。我很荣幸……你排得真深。
You're deep. You should have been on earlier. Yeah. Yeah. When you bury, when you do, when you do like, when you have like a big act, right, you don't have the marquee act first. You have the opening act. You make people wait.
你排得真深。你早该上节目了。对。对。当你埋葬……当你做……当你做那种……当你有一个重头节目时，对吧，你不会把压轴大戏放在最前面。你得有开场暖场节目。你得让人家等。
You have them 114th. You have 230 opening act. It's deeper than that. Hey, Sasha. Sasha. Hey, how are you? Nice to It's deeper than that. Hey, Sasha. Sasha. Hey, how are you? Nice to see you. Nice to meet you, Sasha.
你得让他们排在第114位。你得弄个第230号的开场暖场节目。比这更深。嘿，萨莎。萨莎。嘿，你好吗？很高兴……比这更深。嘿，萨莎。萨莎。嘿，你好吗？很高兴见到你。很高兴认识你，萨莎。
I don't think I've ever met you. Have we never met? That seems bizarre. I'm sorry. Lovely to meet you. Lovely to meet you, too. We'll keep your knees bent on that one. Sasha, you're in Los Angeles or New York?
我觉得我以前从没见过你。我们从来没见过吗？这听起来真诡异。抱歉。很高兴认识你。我也很高兴认识你。那个姿势你得把膝盖弯着点。萨莎，你在洛杉矶还是纽约？
I'm in Morreira in French Polynesia where I live now. Oh, wow. This isn't a bit. Yeah, no, it's a bit. Would you ever live in French Polynesia? Because that sounded great. You know what? I actually considered, I looked into it very thoroughly.
我在法属波利尼西亚的莫雷阿岛，我现在住在那里。噢，哇。这不是个段子吧？对，不，这是个段子。你真的会住在法属波利尼西亚吗？因为听起来太棒了。你知道吗？我其实考虑过，我非常彻底地研究过。
Jokes aside. Truly. That particular spot. During the pandemic, yeah, during the pandemic, we knew we were going to move, but we were looking somewhere in the southern hemisphere because we knew that the flu... The virus doesn't last as long in the southern hemisphere. The northern hemisphere, the virus was crazy strong.
不开玩笑。真的。那个特定的地方。在大流行期间，对，在大流行期间，我们知道我们要搬家，但我们在南半球寻找地方，因为我们知道流感……病毒在南半球存活的时间没有那么长。在北半球，病毒疯狂肆虐。
I think at that point, it was somewhere in the southern hemisphere, and so we had missed the virus. We were advised by someone at Johns Hopkins who I happened to be. Happened to know. And so we looked into French Polynesia. I looked carefully into Tahiti.
我想在那个时候，南半球的某个地方，所以我们就错过了病毒。我们听取了约翰·霍普金斯大学某位我恰好认识的专家的建议。恰好认识。所以我们研究了法属波利尼西亚。我仔细研究了大溪地。
It was interesting. Yeah. There's a bilingual school. Yeah. You know, there's beaches. Have you been to Bora Bora? Have you been to the Brando? Have you been to Moriah? Have you been to the Brando? Have you been to Moriah?
这很有意思。对。那里有双语学校。对。你知道的，有海滩。你去过波拉波拉岛吗？你去过白兰度度假村吗？你去过莫雷阿岛吗？你去过白兰度度假村吗？你去过莫雷阿岛吗？
I have been to Moriah, and I've been to, I've not been to the Brando. It's pretty great. And I have been to Bora Bora. Where's the Brando? And I can tell you everywhere else that I've visited as well. This sounds like real elite fuck off conversation, but.
我去过莫雷阿岛，我去过……我没去过白兰度度假村。那里相当不错。我去过波拉波拉岛。白兰度度假村在哪儿？我还能告诉你所有其他我去过的地方。这听起来像是超级名流滚蛋式的对话，但是……
No, no, no, quite right. Let's discuss the best totems. No, but you know, listeners, I always thought Tahiti was like, you know, on the edge of the earth. It's only three hours past Hawaii for anybody on the West Coast, you know? So people on the West Coast, they go to Hawaii all the time.
不，不，不，完全正确。我们来讨论一下最好的图腾柱吧。不，但你知道的，听众朋友们，我一直以为大溪地就像是在世界的边缘。对于西海岸的任何人来说，它其实只在夏威夷后面三个小时，你知道吗？所以西海岸的人们总是去夏威夷。
It's like Florida for the people in New York. Yeah, it's eight hours. But it's just three hours past that. And you're very familiar with it, Jay, because you actually worked there. So the first time you went down there. Yeah, I did. To fulfill an obligation.
就像纽约人的佛罗里达一样。对，要八个小时。但它只是比那多三个小时。你对它很熟悉，杰伊，因为你真的在那里工作过。所以你第一次去那里的时候。对，我去了。为了履行义务。
Couples retreat, yes. Yeah, yes. By the way, I am happy to discuss French Polynesia. At length. Till the end, yes. Actually, I was in a shark attack there once. You were? I don't know, I was kind of feeding frenzy.
《伴侣度假村》，是的。对，是的。顺便说一句，我很乐意讨论法属波利尼西亚。长话短说。直到永远，是的。其实我还在那儿遭遇过鲨鱼袭击。真的吗？我不知道，当时有点像是一场疯狂的撕咬。
You were in one. In Morreia. I went shark were in a feeding frenzy. You were in one. In Morreia. I went shark diving in Bora Bora. Yeah. Did you, so is that where it came from? Did you go down to dive with sharks and things got a little hot? In those days, I think it's illegal now,
你经历过。在莫雷阿。我去鲨鱼……在一场疯狂的撕咬中。你经历过。在莫雷阿。我去波拉波拉岛进行鲨鱼潜水。对。是不是，这就是那事的起源？你下去和鲨鱼潜水，然后情况变得有点棘手？在那些日子里，我想现在这是非法的，
they used to do something called shark feeding where I was doing my PADI license and then. That's how you get certified as a scuba diver listener, Tracy, PA is from here. Exactly, exactly. And Sean, yeah. And what happened? And then, yeah, the guy I was with,
他们过去常常做一件叫做“喂鲨鱼”的事情，当时我正在考PADI潜水证，然后……听众朋友特蕾西，这就是你如何获得水肺潜水员认证的方式，PA就是从这来的。没错，没错。还有肖恩，对。然后发生了什么？然后，对，和我在一起的那个人，
some French instructor, had basically said, we're going to feed some sharks, and then he puts on a kind of chain mail hand thing. Obviously we're underwater, and he just said, be near me, and it was just me and him. And he basically breaks open a sardine, I remember it. And then I remember seeing the droplets of blood. And then within literally two minutes
某个法国教练，基本上说，我们要去喂几条鲨鱼，然后他戴上了一种类似链甲的手套。显然我们在水下，他只是说，待在我附近，当时就我和他两个人。他基本上撕开了一根沙丁鱼，我记得很清楚。然后我记得我看到了血滴。接着 буквально 简直不到两分钟，
there were 12 sharks around. No way. And then he pulls out this bag, this tuna head, and he's got a chainmail hand on, chainmail kind of glove on, and they start eating the thing. And it's really interesting and I'm there opposite. Then they get carried away. hand on, chainmail kind of glove on, and they start eating the thing. And it's really interesting, and I'm there opposite.
周围就出现了12条鲨鱼。不会吧。然后他掏出一个袋子，里面是一个金枪鱼头，他戴着一只链甲手，一种链甲手套，然后它们开始吃那个东西。这真的很有意思，而我就站在对面。然后它们忘形了……戴着链甲手套，它们开始吃那个东西。这真的很有意思，而我就站在对面。
Then they get carried away, and there's a feeding frenzy, and you can't see anything. And he's looking at you with eyebrows high, like isn't this fine? He's not looking at me. His glove gets knocked off, and his regulator gets knocked out of his mouth, and then he leaves. He needs some air.
接着它们忘形了，现场陷入疯狂的撕咬，你什么也看不见。而他睁大眼睛看着你，好像在说这不是很棒吗？他才没有看着我。他的手套被打掉了，他的调节器也被从嘴里打掉了，然后他就游走了。他需要喘口气。
He goes up and leaves me alone with the 12 sharks. That are, and I can't see a thing. Does he put up one finger like, I'll be right back. No, nothing, it was literally nothing. I went down there with a guy, he put a tuna head in his wetsuit, right in the front of his wetsuit, in order to have all the sharks, it was a big group of us. And, I mean, this was planned.
他浮上去把我一个人留在12条鲨鱼中间。它们是……而且我什么也看不见。他有没有竖起一根手指，好像在说“我马上回来”？不，完全没有，简直什么都没有。我和一个家伙一起下去了，他在潜水服里塞了一个金枪鱼头，就在潜水服的正前方，为了吸引所有的鲨鱼，我们是一大群人。而且，我的意思是，这是计划好的。
And he said not to worry about it. And we did a little bit and then it was okay. And you can see in their eyes that they're not interested in you. Like, you know, sharks are always scary when your head's kind of just above the water. You don't know what's going on below. But once you get under and you can look at a shark,
他说不用担心。我们做了一会儿，然后觉得还行。你能从它们的眼睛里看出它们对你不感兴趣。就像，你知道的，当你的头刚好在水面上时，鲨鱼总是很吓人。你不知道下面发生了什么。但一旦你潜下去，你能看着一条鲨鱼，
look at you and then kind of swim away your fear of sharks goes away instantly I highly recommend it that did not happen when the sharks knocked the regulator out of his mouth Knocked the gloves off and he swam away Sean You told me once you walked out of a Ralph's with like 12 cans of tuna in your pants, right? in your pants, right? Is that a true story? Did that happen or was that just true? That was like a dream come true, yeah. But Sasha, you sound like that was a surprise
看着你然后游开，你对鲨鱼的恐惧瞬间就消失了，我强烈推荐。当鲨鱼把调节器从他嘴里打掉、打掉手套、他游走的时候，可没发生这种事。肖恩，你曾经告诉我，你从拉尔夫超市走出来时，裤子里塞了大约12罐金枪鱼，对吧？塞在裤子里，对吧？那是真事吗？发生过还是只是……那简直就像梦想成真一样，对吧。但萨莎，听起来你对事情急转直下感到很意外。
that it went awry. I was, and I basically started hyperventilating. I mean, this was my second time diving in my life. Yeah, but I mean like. And then actually the guy put his regulator back on, put the glove back, because he'd left me alone. Went back down and then the first shark went to attack him and he punched it in the nose.
我当时确实很意外，我基本上开始过度换气了。我是说，这是我这辈子第二次潜水。对，但我的意思是……然后那个家伙把调节器戴了回去，把手套戴好，因为他刚才把我一个人留下了。又潜回水里，然后第一条鲨鱼去攻击他，他一拳打在它的鼻子上。
I mean this is not good for animal rights lovers out there. No, but that's what you're supposed to do. He's defending himself, that's okay. Yeah. I mean if the shark is eating you and you're just going, no, I didn't want to punch it in the nose. You can hurt me, I don't want to hurt you. Yeah, give me a break. No, you're just going, no, I didn't want to punch it in the nose. You can hurt me, I don't want to hurt you. Yeah, give me a break.
我的意思是，这对动物权利爱好者来说可不是什么好事。不，但那是你该做的。他在自卫，那没关系。对。我的意思是，如果鲨鱼正在吃你，而你却在说：“不，我不想打它的鼻子。你可以伤害我，但我不想伤害你。”得了吧。不，你只是在说：“不，我不想打它的鼻子。你可以伤害我，但我不想伤害你。得了吧。”
No, you're allowed. Are you sure that the shark wasn't just coming to him for more sort of that blood? He wasn't trying to bite the guy, was he? I don't think so. I think they were just in a frenzy. He headbutted the big shark. Did they interview the shark after? Did they get a picture?
不，这是允许的。你确定那条鲨鱼不是为了找他要更多那种血才过来的吗？他当时不是在试图咬那个家伙吧？我不这么认为。我觉得它们只是陷入了疯狂。他用头撞了那条大鲨鱼。事后他们采访那条鲨鱼了吗？他们拍到照片了吗？
He headbutted him. He headbutted one of the sharks. The lemon shark, which I think was kind of about 12 feet long. He headbutted one of the sharks. The lemon shark, which I think was kind of about 12 feet long. He headbutted that shark. No, of course you have to. In France we headbutt the shark. Afterwards I did go up to him and I said, has anyone...
他用头撞了它。他用头撞了其中一条鲨鱼。那条柠檬鲨，我想大约有12英尺长。他用头撞了那条鲨鱼。不，你当然得这么做。在法国，我们用头撞鲨鱼。事后我确实走过去对他说：“有没有人……”
In the end, basically he came over to me, checked my oxygen, and I completely run out of oxygen. And then we did some emergency procedure. Where you take his regulator, he puts it in your mouth and then we did some emergency procedure. Where you know, you take his regulator, you know, he puts it in your mouth and you put yours in his mouth. He's like, we both have to get in the same wetsuit, don't worry, it's fine. This is how we regulate. This is a very long ruse.
最后，基本上他朝我游过来，检查我的氧气，而我的氧气已经完全耗尽了。然后我们做了一些紧急程序。就是你拿走他的调节器，他把它放进你的嘴里，然后我们做了一些紧急程序。你知道的，你拿走他的调节器，你知道的，他把它放进你的嘴里，你把你的放进他的嘴里。他就像是：“我们俩得钻进同一件潜水服里，别担心，没事的。”这就是我们调节的方式。这是一个非常漫长的恶作剧。
We're both in this, we go down below. This hasn't wrecked your love of scuba diving though, has it? No, no, no, I went back the next day. I did say to him, I said, has anyone ever got hurt on any of your dives? And he said, two people have died. No way, for real. Seriously. But it was painless.
我们俩都在里面，我们潜到了水底。不过这并没有毁掉你对水肺潜水的热爱，对吧？没有，没有，没有，我第二天又回去了。我确实对他说过，我说：“有没有人在你的任何潜水活动中受过伤？”他说：“死过两个人。”不会吧，说真的。真的。但过程很痛苦吗？
Yeah, he was a cave diver. Those guys are completely crazy, and he basically missed the fun of, and the thrill of cave diving. I think scuba diving is like, scuba diving is the most magical thing I've ever done. I would love to do it more and more. But what if you said, have anybody ever done,
不，他是名洞穴潜水员。那些家伙完全是疯子，他基本上错过了洞穴潜水的乐趣和刺激。我觉得水肺潜水就像是……水肺潜水是我这辈子做过最神奇的事。我很想更多更多地去潜水。但如果你问：“有没有人死过？”
and he goes, yes, two people, and you said they, like in a cave, where he goes, no, I murdered them. This was above, this was not in the water. No, the night before I murdered them in the room, I strangled them. Do you do a lot of that stuff, Sasha? Like do you thrill seek?
他说：“对，两个人。”然后你问：“是在洞穴里吗？”他说：“不，我谋杀了他们。”这不是在水下发生的。不，前一天晚上我在房间里谋杀了他们，我勒死了他们。你经常干那种事吗，萨莎？比如你喜欢寻求刺激吗？
Are you a thrill seeker? Not really, no, no, no, no. Have you ever skydived? Would you? I have not, I would not. Have you, have you? I was a week away from it and then I canceled it because I said to myself,
你是个寻求刺激的人吗？其实没有，不，不，不，不。你跳过伞吗？你会吗？我没有，我也不会。你呢，你跳过吗？我离它只有一周的时间，然后我取消了，因为我对自己说：
okay, what do you think you'd feel at the end? And then I realized all I would feel is relief. And then I thought, well, I've just had my first kid and I shouldn't be doing things that I'm excited about having gotten away with it. You know, like no longer should I be doing things I get away with. And so I stopped.
“好吧，你觉得结束时会有什么感觉？”然后我意识到我唯一的感受就是解脱。接着我想，好吧，我刚有了第一个孩子，我不应该去做那些侥幸成功后会感到兴奋的事。你知道的，我不应该再做那些靠侥幸过关的事了。所以我停下来了。
I said, you know what, I don't wanna do it. And none of you guys have done it. Would all three of you do it? I did the simulation thing, but not really. What do you mean, the fucking little fly suit at Universal Studios? You get the two with the air? No, that doesn't count. Does it count?
我说：“你知道吗，我不想这么做。”你们谁都没跳过吗？你们三个会去跳吗？我玩过模拟器，但不是真的。什么意思，环球影城的那个搞笑小飞行服吗？就是那个有风吹的？不，那不算。这算吗？
So, Sasha Baroncon, let's drop the Baron, huh? Just to make me even more Jewish. Well, let's... But wait, Baron is not a part of the last name, is it? Is that your middle name? It's part of the last name, yeah. Oh, not a part of the last name, is it, is it just, is that your middle name? It's part of the last name, yeah. Oh, it's part of the last name, oh, got it. So, Sasha, your blend of comedy and,
所以，萨莎·拜伦·科恩，我们把“拜伦”去掉吧？好让我显得更犹太人一点。好吧，我们……等等，“拜伦”不是姓氏的一部分吗？那是你的中间名吗？它是姓氏的一部分，对。噢，不是姓氏的一部分吗？是吗？那是你的中间名吗？它是姓氏的一部分，对。噢，它是姓氏的一部分，哦，明白了。所以，萨莎，你那将喜剧与……
for lack of a better term, education, as I said in the intro, I find personally so admirable and like you make the medicine go down super easy for ding-dongs like me in the stuff you shine a light on, not only just on issues, but also sort of ethics and bigotry and et cetera, et cetera. Where does that come, well, I kind of know where it comes from, but tell the audience, like, when did you figure out
用词不当的话说，教育，正如我在开场白中所说，我个人觉得非常令人钦佩，就像你让像我这样的笨蛋非常容易地把苦药咽下去一样，你揭露的不仅是各种问题，还有道德、偏见等等等等。这源于……好吧，我大概知道它源于哪里，但跟观众讲讲吧，你是从什么时候发现
you could blend your social awareness with your comedic talents? Firstly, thank you very much for that description. Let's take it down. It was lovely, I could spend all day on that. But please don't. Ha ha ha! I think it was the first time... Actually, the second time I did Borat.
你可以把社会觉醒和你的喜剧天赋融合在一起的呢？首先，非常感谢你对我的评价。我们低调点。这太美妙了，我可以一整天都聊这个。但请别这样。哈哈哈哈！我想那是第一次……其实是我第二次扮演波at。
So basically, Borat was created... I was doing like a satellite TV show called F2F. Well, I was the host of it. It was a discussion show for teenage kids. We talked about everything. And it talked about teen topics. called F2F, where I was the host of there. It was a discussion show for teenage kids. We talked about everything. And it talked about teen topics. And I wanted to be a comedian.
所以基本上，波拉特这个角色的诞生……当时我在做一个叫《F2F》的卫星电视节目。嗯，我是主持人。那是一个针对青少年的讨论节目。我们无所不谈。谈论的都是青少年话题……叫《F2F》，我是那里的主持人。那是一个针对青少年的讨论节目。我们无所不谈。谈论的都是青少年话题。而我想成为一名喜剧演员。
And so I would go and pre-record characters that I could throw to. And basically, I went out once, and I had a kind of skateboarding character that was an early form of Ali G and then I basically saw some real skateboarders and the guy I was with, this sort of old director from E-Link Studios who had lost all his money and was working on this really shitty satellite TV show, I said look, those guys look like me. I go, do you think I should talk to them?
所以我经常去预先录制一些角色，我可以把他们串联起来。基本上，有一次我出去了，我有一个类似滑板少年的角色，那是阿里·G（Ali G）的早期雏形，然后我基本上看到了一些真正的滑板少年，和我在一起的那个人，是伊灵制片厂（Ealing Studios）的一个老导演，他输光了所有的钱，正在这个极其糟糕的卫星电视节目里工作，我说：“看，那些家伙看起来和我挺像的。”我说：“你觉得我应该去和他们谈谈吗？”
And he said, 100%. So I go over to these guys, and I'm basically on my skateboard, and I'm playing this early Ali G character, and they thought I was real. And after about three minutes, I said, guys, you know, I'm not, you know, I'm not real. This is just, you know, I'm playing along. They were completely freaked out.
他说：“百分之百。”于是我走向那些家伙，我基本上踩着滑板，扮演着这个早期的阿里·G角色，他们以为我是真的。大约三分钟后，我说：“伙计们，你知道的，我不是，你知道的，我不是真的。这只是，你知道的，我是在陪你们玩。”他们彻底吓坏了。
And then I, a tourist bus came, I jumped on the tourist bus, I commandeered it, I started rapping, got off the bus, went into a pub, started- What year was this, Sasha, what year was this maybe? This was, I think, 1995 or four. Okay. Anyway, I basically go into a pub, I start break dancing, they call the police,
然后我，一辆旅游巴士开过来了，我跳上了旅游巴士，我把它劫持了，我开始说唱，下了车，走进一家酒吧，开始……这是哪一年，萨莎，这大概是哪一年？这大概是1995年或1994年。好吧。总之，我基本上走进了一家酒吧，我开始跳霹雳舞，他们报了警，
I go into some big business, I claim that my dad's upstairs and he's the CEO, they call security. We run back to this live TV show, I run, they put on my normal clothes, and this guy, this legendary guy, who's an editor at Ealing Studios, is editing while I'm on air.
我走进一家大公司，我宣称我爸爸在楼上，他是首席执行官，他们叫了保安。我们跑回这个直播电视节目，我跑进去，他们帮我换回正常的衣服，而这个家伙，这个传奇人物，伊灵制片厂的剪辑师，正在我直播的时候进行剪辑。
This is the days of pneumatics. This is, he's like cutting, you know, every time he's losing forefront, and he's adding music, and this guy was the kind of legendary guy. And I'm cutting to this stuff, and it's me with real people, so it was the first time that it was a comic character
那是使用磁带（pneumatics）的年代。这是，他在剪辑，你知道的，他每一次都在损失画幅（forefront），他在添加音乐，这个家伙是个传奇人物。我切入这些素材，里面有我和真人的互动，所以这是我第一次将喜剧角色
with real people. And you realize that you could Trojan horse some of the social commentary inside a comedy, yeah? You're right, I'm not really answering your question at all. This was like the first time I ever did characters in the real world. Because you weren't doing that shit yet. Like even Ali G, you weren't really,
融入真人世界中。你意识到你可以把一些社会评论作为“特洛伊木马”藏在喜剧里面，对吧？你说得对，我根本没回答你的问题。这是我第一次在现实世界中扮演角色。因为你当时还没搞那些破事呢。就像哪怕是阿里·G，你其实也并没有……
early on Ali G, you weren't really making commentary. You were just fucking with people. Yeah. Early on. Well, but you were exposing sort of the low brow perspective on certain things that deserve a high brow analysis. Yeah? I think in a way, Ali G was kind of a undermining of the establishment.
早期的阿里·G，你其实并没有做太多评论。你只是在耍人玩。对。早期的时候。好吧，但你是在揭露某些本该接受高级分析的事物背后那种低级的视角。是吗？我想在某种程度上，阿里·G是对建制的一种破坏。
It was essentially saying, okay, these people that run society, they are completely out of touch with society so much that they will believe that this guy is real, despite him asking the most absurd questions ever. Can I tell you, Sasha, I think I've told you this, and JB, you might know this, but I don't mean to speak ill of the dead.
它本质上是在说：“好吧，这些统治社会的人，他们与社会完全脱节，脱节到居然会相信这个家伙是真的，尽管他问出了史上最荒谬的问题。”我能告诉你吗，萨莎，我觉得我可能跟你说过这个，JB，你可能也知道，但我无意说死者的坏话。
But they don't give a shit. You're not going to criticize Hitler again, are you? No, I told you I wouldn't ever. Remember, you made me, I signed a... I made a promise to him. Yeah, stop it. I was in tears, yeah. You were an absolute wreck.
但他们根本不在乎。你不会又要批评希特勒了吧？不，我告诉过你我再也不会了。记住，你让我这么做的，我签了一个……我向他许过诺。对，住手。我当时泪流满面，对。你当时整个人彻底崩溃了。
I was furious. I was weeping. It's one of the weirdest positions. I was weeping at the Vanity Fair party when you were... It's not a position you think Sasha would have, but boy, no, was years ago, right after it aired, and I want to say about 2003, 2004, something like that, you were still doing LAG at the time, it was before Borat.
我气疯了。我在哭泣。这是最奇怪的立场之一。我在名利场派对上哭泣，当时你正在……这不是你想象中萨莎会有的立场，但天哪，不，那是多年前的事了，就在节目播出后不久，我想大概是2003年、2004年左右，你当时还在演《阿里·G秀》，在《波拉特》之前。
And I was at a party with, because he was on Arrested Development, with James Lipton. Jason, you were there too. And I had just seen it, and I said to James Lipton, I go, oh, I saw you on LAG, and I said, God, that was so funny. The actor studio guy? The actor studio guy, yeah.
我在一个派对上，因为他参演了《发展受阻》，遇到了詹姆斯·利普顿（James Lipton）。杰森，你也在场。我当时刚看过那个节目，我对詹姆斯·利普顿说：“哦，我在《阿里·G秀》里看到你了，天哪，太搞笑了。”那个演员工作室的人？那个演员工作室的人，对。
And he was on Arrested Development. He played the warden of the prison. That's great. Warden Gentles? Gentiles? Yeah, yeah, that's right. I think that's right. And it's a really funny bit to have a Mr. Warden, right?
他参演了《发展受阻》。他扮演监狱的典狱长。太棒了。詹特尔斯典狱长？詹蒂莱斯？对，对，没错。我想是这样的。让一个典狱长先生来演戏，这真的是一个非常搞笑的包袱，对吧？
And the whole time he's really just trying to get them all to mount a play, like a musical. But he says, I said, yeah, I saw your analogy, God, that was so funny, and he goes, I knew when he came in, I knew that it was a bit, and he went on this whole thing, and I just watched it, and I'm thinking like, no, you didn't. No, he had absolutely no idea,
而整个过程他其实只是想让他们都排练一出戏，比如一部音乐剧。但他说，我说：“对，我看过你的访谈，天哪，太搞笑了。”然后他说：“他进来的时候我就知道这是个恶作剧。”他滔滔不绝地说了这一大堆，而我当时就看着他，心想：不，你根本不知道。不，他完全没有概念，
because he took me off camera after we'd finished the interview, back to the other room, and so, you know, I was still in character, he completely believed who I was. And I think he showed me like a painting of a naked woman. Yes, is that possible? It's of his wife, yeah it is, yeah.
因为在我们结束采访后，他把我带到了镜头之外的另一个房间，所以，你知道的，我当时还沉浸在角色中，他完全相信了我就是那个人。而且我想他还给我看了一幅裸体女人的画。是的，这可能吗？那是他妻子，对，确实是，对。
Yeah, and he goes, that is my wife. Which you wouldn't do if you thought, and I was like, young man, yo, she is, man, I would bone that, yo. Somebody else, wait, you know how I know that? Somebody else, Sasha, has told me that very same thing that he turned back and said, this is the naked picture painting of my wife.
对，他说：“那是我的妻子。”如果你觉得这是个恶作剧，你绝不会这么做，而我当时说：“年轻的朋友，天哪，她，老兄，我会跟她上床的，老兄。”另一个人，等等，你知道我是怎么知道这事的吗？另一个人，萨莎，也跟我说过同样的话，说他转过身来指着说：“这是我妻子的裸体画。”
There we go, you verified the story. That is fact checking. We have just fact checked. There you go. We've established me as a reliable witness. And that started the classic line from Borat of, it's my wife, right? Yeah, it's my naked wife James Lipton we it was beautiful by the way. She was beautiful. She was classically if we use those kind of ways to categorize women Sure, what does it mean? Of course?
这就对了，你证实了这个故事。这就是事实核查。我们刚刚核查了事实。你看。我们确立了我作为一个可靠目击者的地位。这就引出了《波拉特》中的经典台词：“这是我老婆，对吧？”对，那是我的裸体妻子詹姆斯·利普顿，我们……顺便说一句，她很漂亮。她很漂亮。如果我们可以用那种方式来把女人分类的话……当然，那是什么意思？当然。
We'll be right back And now back to the show. At the beginning when I asked you about the risk taking, I was like, would you do anything else other than swim with the sharks or whatever? And you said, no, absolutely not. We talk about skydiving. I just realizing, what you do is so high risk.
我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。一开始我问你关于冒险的问题时，我说你会不会除了和鲨鱼一起游泳之外还做别的什么，你说“不，绝对不会”。我们聊到高空跳伞。我刚刚意识到，你做的事情风险太高了。
So risky, oh my God. So it's like that must fulfill some kind of like, thrusting you. Yeah, the fear, like you love that kind of rush of like, you're about to get caught. Right, you're not doing that as much anymore, correct? Is that because you're just sort of like older and wiser and you don't want to get hit or run anymore?
太危险了，天哪。所以这一定满足了某种……让你热血沸腾的东西。对，这种恐惧，就像你喜欢那种即将被抓包的刺激感。对吧？你现在不怎么做那种事了吧，对吗？是不是因为你年纪大了、更明智了，所以不想再挨揍或者惹上官司了？
Well, the last... Sorry, sorry. Yeah, no, end of question. Interrupted slightly. I thought I was waiting for that sliver. You threw me a line. I went in a little early. No, I can go on. And then there was an orb. Thank you for that.
嗯，最后一次……抱歉，抱歉。对，不，你问吧。稍微被打断了一下。我以为我在等那个空档。我接话稍微早了一点。不，我可以继续。然后出现了一个球体。谢谢你。
Then there was an orb. Well, the last Borat movie, there was quite a lot of that stuff and actually, I mean, we did, there was a scene at a gun rally which was, got quite hairy. I remember reading about that, yeah. Yes, it was, you know, I mean, people were semi-automatics and automatics in the audience and it was a militia, unfortunately, that had organized it that then didn't take it very well. And I was singing a song called The Wuhan Flu. That's right.
然后出现了一个球体。好吧，最后一部《波拉特》电影里，有很多那样的内容，实际上，我的意思是，我们拍过，有一个在持枪集会上的场景，相当惊险。我记得读到过那篇报道，对。是的，那次，你知道的，我的意思是，观众席里有人拿着半自动和全自动武器，那是一个民兵组织，不幸的是，他们组织了那场活动，结果却对此很不高兴。我当时在唱一首叫《武汉流感》的歌。没错。
Everybody what I gotta do. I can't even remember it. I mean, where does the fearlessness come from though? I mean, fortunately. Well, there, I'll tell you the truth with that scene because we knew that there were going to be, you know, basically it was a gun rally, and everyone was talking about something.
每个人都得听我的。我甚至记不清了。我的意思是，这种无所畏惧是从哪里来的呢？我是说，幸运的是。好吧，关于那个场景，我跟你说实话，因为我们知道将会……你知道的，基本上那是一场持枪集会，每个人都在谈论某事。
It was in the middle of COVID, we were the only movie shooting, and so, you know, my security said, listen, you need to have a bulletproof vest on. And so I put on the bulletproof vest, and I said, they go, that's fine for pistols. And they said, I go, once if somebody shoots the, you shoots the semi-automatic?
那是疫情期间，我们是唯一在拍摄的电影，所以，你知道的，我的保安说：“听着，你得穿上防弹衣。”所以我穿上了防弹衣，我说，他们说：“这防手枪没问题。”然后我说：“如果有人开枪呢？如果有人用半自动步枪开枪呢？”
And, you know, it's not just one person. So they built, so I was singing on stage, so they built an amplifier that was pretty much bombproof. So they basically said, you know, if people start really shooting with the semi-automatics, go behind the amplifier and you'll be safe. Jesus! It's unbelievable. And so the thing is, you know, you're in the scene, I'm on stage, and you know, you have this kind of conflict between, you know, I'm terrified, and then you always have, I need
而且，你知道的，不只是一个人。所以他们建造了一个……我在舞台上唱歌，所以他们建造了一个几乎可以防爆的扩音器。所以他们基本上说：“你知道的，如果人们真的开始用半自动步枪开枪，就躲到扩音器后面，你就会安全。”天哪！这太不可思议了。所以问题是，你知道的，你正在拍这场戏，我在舞台上，你知道的，你内心有一种冲突，你知道的，我很恐慌，然后你心里又总有一个声音：我需要
to get the scene. So you want to, so I was doing, you know, the same verse again, because I felt I hadn't got a good take of it. People were getting more and more, you know, they realized at some point that it was me on stage. There was somebody actually undercover from Black Lives Matter had infiltrated this gun rally. And basically they recognized me and word spread that it was me. Black Lives Matter had infiltrated this gun rally.
拍好这个镜头。所以你想，所以我把同一段歌词又唱了一遍，因为我觉得刚才那条没拍好。人们越来越……你知道的，他们在大庭广众之下终于意识到舞台上的人是我。实际上有一个黑命贵（Black Lives Matter）的卧底混进了这个持枪集会。然后他们认出了我，消息传开了，说那是我。黑命贵（Black Lives Matter）混进了这个持枪集会。
Yeah. And basically they recognized me and word spread that it was me. And then people started trying to storm the stage. Right, because they realized they were getting clowned. Yeah. And obviously they all had guns. And then, but I'm trying to get the scene and obviously to do as many different takes
对。然后他们认出了我，消息传开了，说那是我。接着人们开始试图冲击舞台。对，因为他们意识到自己被耍了。对。而且显然他们都有枪。然后，但我正努力拍好这场戏，显然要拍尽可能多的不同版本，
and eventually they did storm the stage and actually somebody pulled a gun. And luckily I had a very good bodyguard at the time who managed to... Make a bullet. Yeah, he's dead but he gave him such a beautiful funeral. That's why you said at the time. Yeah, he was such a, he went away so well.
最后他们真的冲上了舞台，实际上有人拔出了枪。幸运的是我当时有一个非常好的保镖，他设法……挡下一颗子弹。对，他死了，但他给他办了一场非常体面的葬礼。这就是为什么你刚才说“当时”。对，他太棒了，他走得很安详。
He had such a beautiful and reasonable funeral. No. It's funny you mention reasonable because I was going to say as part of this and the situation you describe, you have to deal with a lot of people who some might consider to be unreasonable, to be extremists in certain ways. My question is, when you deal with all these people and you're revealing all this or pulling back the sort of the covers on all this kind of shit,
他办了一场如此美好又合乎情理的葬礼。不。你提到“合乎情理”真搞笑，因为我本来想说，作为其中的一部分以及你所描述的那种情况，你必须对付很多被某些人认为是不合理的人，在某些方面可以说是极端分子。我的问题是，当你与所有人打交道，并且你正在揭露所有这些或者揭开所有这些破事时，
do you ever have a moment where you go, you know what, this person is kind of a good person. They're just really, they've just gotten off on the wrong path. Or misinformed. I'm sure some of them are despicable, yeah, but just some are misinformed, but actually at their heart, they're kind really, they've just gotten off on the wrong path. Or misinformed. I'm sure some of them are despicable, yeah, but just some are misinformed, but actually at their heart they're kind of good people.
你有没有过这样一个时刻，你会觉得：“你知道吗，这个人其实是个好人。他们只是……走错了路。”或者被误导了。我确信他们当中有些人十恶不赦，对吧，但只是有些人被误导了，实际上他们的内心深处还是挺善良的人。
Yes, I mean, on the last movie as well, there were these two guys I spent three days in a house with, called Jim and Jerry. And they were... Wait, this is Bruno, right? No, this was Bull Rat 2. Oh, right, right, right. You know, they believe that Hillary Clinton
是的，我是说，在上一部电影里也是，有两个家伙我和他们在房子里待了三天，叫吉姆和杰瑞。他们是……等等，这是《布鲁诺》里的吗？不，这是《波拉特2》。哦，对，对，对。你知道的，他们相信希拉里·克林顿
drank the blood of children and, you know, COVID was a conspiracy and... And that Hillary had killed kids and all. But they were actually... They were nice people. They were good people. They were just... misinformed. And so you suddenly realize they're,
喝小孩的血，而且，你知道的，新冠肺炎是一场阴谋，还有……希拉里杀害了小孩子之类的一切。但他们实际上……他们是好人。他们是善良的人。他们只是……被误导了。所以你突然意识到他们是……
and they were actually feminists because, well, when I was being, when Borat was being a misogynist about his daughter, he was like, they took it upon themselves to teach me that it was important to be respectful to your daughter, and if she wanted to do her own thing, she should do. So they were actually good guys and you suddenly realized,
而且他们实际上还是女权主义者，因为，好吧，当我扮演波拉特，对他的女儿发表大男子主义言论时，他们主动承担起教育我的责任，告诉我尊重女儿是多么重要，如果她想做自己的事，就应该让她去做。所以他们其实是好人，你突然意识到，
and it was a surprise, right, because they had those views and you want to dismiss these people as being horrific. And then you suddenly realize that actually any good person, if they're fed a set of ideas and set of information that's wrong can believe conspiracy theories that ultimately lead to horrific stuff. Right? Right?
这挺让人意外的，对吧，因为他们有那些观点，而你本来想把这些人斥为十恶不赦的混蛋。然后你突然意识到，其实任何一个好人，如果被灌输了一套错误的想法和错误的信息，都有可能相信最终导致可怕后果的阴谋烈论。对吧？对吧？
Well, I mean, you know, we, at the risk of stepping towards political, which we try not to do on this, because God knows people get enough of that shit away from here. Tell me about it. But just on the subject, do you feel hopeful at all that there's a scenario of possibility where those who feel so disenfranchised and aggrieved can be brought into a sense of,
好吧，我的意思是，你知道的，我们，冒着向政治靠拢的风险，我们尽量在这档节目中避免谈论政治，因为天哪，人们在别的地方已经受够了那些狗屁倒灶的事了。可不是嘛。但就这个话题而言，你是否抱有一丝希望，觉得存在这样一种可能性，即那些感到被剥夺权利和遭受委屈的人，能够被引导产生一种……
well, actually, I guess we aren't, you know, we needn't be tribalized. We can all kind of get along and work as one. Like, do you see that as a possibility soon? I don't, given the state of the current, you know, internet and information laws, basically. Yeah, that possibly you can penetrate this misinformation and make it healthy.
好吧，其实，我想我们并非……我们不需要被部落化。我们都可以和睦相处，作为一个整体共同努力。就像，你认为这在不久的将来有可能实现吗？我不觉得，考虑到当前（你知道的）互联网和信息法的现状，基本上是这样。对，可能很难穿透这种错误信息并让它恢复健康。
Well, you're being fed so much stuff that polarizes you. Yeah. If you look at the craziness that is going on in the world, everything has been accelerating since social media came along. So until really, in my opinion, until you actually get laws that, you know, get legislation that curbs the power of those social media companies and says,
好吧，你被灌输了太多两极分化的东西。是的。如果你看看世界上发生的疯狂事情，自从社交媒体出现以来，一切都在加速发展。所以直到现在，在我看来，直到你真正出台法律，你知道，制定立法来遏制这些社交媒体公司的权力，并说，
all right, actually you can't spread lies like this that kill people or that completely undermine democracy. And you are legitimately educated on this issue of free speech versus, you know, trying to keep the social media sites from being regulated. So my question to you is, what is that difference between, well, free speech should be given to everybody, but you can't yell fire in a crowded theater?
好吧，实际上你不能传播这种会杀人或彻底破坏民主的谎言。而且在这个关于言论自由与试图阻止社交媒体网站被监管的问题上，你受到了合法的教育。所以我的问题是，言论自由应该赋予每个人，但你不能在拥挤的电影院里大喊失火，这两者之间的区别是什么？
So what is that line and who is the one that can say, oh yeah, this qualifies as you can't yell fire in a crowded theater, so therefore you can't say that? Like who decides what statements get put in that category? I mean these are very big questions, huge. And they kind of vary from country to country. So in England, Australia, and Germany, you have laws about hate speech
那么这条界限是什么？谁能说，哦，对，这符合“你不能在拥挤的电影院里大喊失火”的情况，所以因此你不能那样说？就像是谁来决定哪些言论被归入那个类别？我的意思是，这些是非常大的问题，巨大的问题。而且它们因国家而异。所以在英国、澳大利亚和德国，你有关于仇恨言论的法律。
and about certain types of misinformation. In America, obviously, you have complete free speech, but it's not up to those- Except for yelling fire. Yes, well, actually, you kind of can at the moment. I mean, the internet companies, because they're not regulated because of this thing called Section 230 230 they can
以及关于某些类型的虚假信息的法律。在美国，显然，你有完全的言论自由，但这不是由那些——除了大喊失火。是的，嗯，实际上，你现在某种程度上还可以。我的意思是，互联网公司，因为它们不受监管，因为有个东西叫第230条，它们可以
put out which is a free speech thing right section 230 isn't really about free speech it basically says you can't sue them so once you can't sue a company you know they have no obligation to you know maintain the free speech of the United States in the same way that a restaurant can say, you know what, I'm going to throw you out of the restaurant for saying this or that, or you know, we're having that KKK hood here. So I think the fact, you know, they're saying that they care about free speech,
发布内容，这算是一个言论自由的东西，对吧？第230条其实并不是关于言论自由的，它基本上是说你不能起诉它们。所以一旦你不能起诉一家公司，你知道，它们就没有义务去维护美国的言论自由，就像一家餐馆可以跟你说，你知道吗，我要把你赶出餐馆，因为你说了这个或那个，或者你知道，我们这里有3K党的头套。所以我觉得事实是，你知道，它们说它们关心言论自由，
basically because it's fantastic for their business model. It means that they can have every single person in the world can be on Meta, can be on Instagram, can be on X. They don't care really about free speech. No, look at Elon Musk who consistently talks about free speech. And he'll do that, and then out of the other side of his mouth, he's sort of decrying the government for doing X, Y, and Z, or he's kicking people off, or he's muting them on Twitter.
基本上是因为这对其商业模式极其有利。这意味着世界上每一个人都可以使用Meta、Instagram、X。它们其实根本不在乎言论自由。不，看看埃隆·马斯克，他一直在谈论言论自由。他会这么说，然后又出尔反尔，一边指责政府做这做那，一边又在推特上把人踢出去或者禁言。
I actually don't want to talk about this, I don't want to give him any more airtime. The guy's such a, in my opinion, so fucking unfunny, it's crazy, which is I think the most damning thing about, one of, no, a lot of damning things, but the fact is how profoundly unfucking funny he is is so astonishing. And that's why your work and your courage, quite frankly,
我其实不想谈这个，我不想再给他任何曝光度了。这家伙，依我之见，太特么不好笑了，简直疯狂，我认为这是最令人发指的事情之一，不，有很多令人发指的事情，但事实是，他到底有多特么不好笑，简直让人震惊。这就是为什么你的作品和你的勇气，坦白说，
in my opinion, is so valuable. And I'd take it, I wish you were back on a weekly show, I'd take it once a week. So thank you for all of that. I think you're right. Yeah, JB, we need to have that sort of, you need to be in there lampooning and really showing, shedding light on the hypocrisy alone
在我看来，是如此宝贵。我宁愿，我希望你能回到周播节目中，我每周看一次都行。所以谢谢你所做的一切。我想你是对的。是的，JB，我们需要那种，你需要去讽刺，真正展现出来，仅仅是揭露虚伪
is so fucking jarring, right? Yeah, it's refreshing to- I mean, it must be fun for you when you have those people say, when you put them in that position and then they say the thing that you're like, "'Fuckin' hell, this is unreal.'" Yeah, yeah.
就特么够让人震惊的了，对吧？是的，这真让人耳目一新——我的意思是，当那些人说，当你把他们置于那种境地，然后他们说出让你觉得“他妈的，这太不真实了”的话时，对你来说一定很有趣吧。对，对。
I mean, obviously it's horrific, but you go, you know, while I'm actually in the room, I'm editing the scene as well. So in my head, I'm going, you go, oh, you know, while I'm actually in the room, I'm editing the scene as well. So in my head, I'm going, you know, once they've got the thing, I go, oh, that's great. And now one follow-up question, bang, okay, now I'm going to move on to the next bit. You know, because there's obviously no director there.
我的意思是，这显然很可怕，但你会觉得，你知道，当我在现场的时候，其实我也在剪辑这个场景。所以在我的脑海里，我在想，你会想，哦，你知道，当我在现场的时候，其实我也在剪辑这个场景。所以在我的脑海里，我在想，你知道，一旦他们说了那句话，我就想，哦，太棒了。现在还有一个后续问题，砰，好的，现在我要进入下一个部分了。你知道，因为现场显然没有导演。
Yeah. Where did you, where did, you know, I've always been taken by your... Figure. Your, yeah, your silhouette. You've always been taken by your... Figure. Yeah, your silhouette. It is surprisingly, think more about that. I mean, the show. Tell me more about that.
是的。你在哪里，你——你知道，我一直对你的……身材。你的，是的，你的轮廓。我一直对你的……身材。是的，你的轮廓。这真让人惊讶，多想想这个。我是说，这个节目。跟我多说说这个。
What do you mean, what do you mean by figure? Stay on that topic, what do you mean? It's surprisingly. It's surprisingly, but I did say sneaky handsome in the intro, I believe. Thank you, thank you. But the, and you did start as a model, but we don't need to talk about that.
你什么意思，你说的身材是什么意思？别离开这个话题，你到底什么意思？这真让人惊讶。这真让人惊讶，不过我在开场白里确实说过你狡猾地帅，我相信。谢谢，谢谢。但是，你确实是以模特身份出道的，但我们不需要谈这个。
You know. More in Wikipedia accuracy. But your ability as an actor is like, breathtaking might be overstating it, but I don't have a better word. I don't know, I don't know. I'm just kidding. But it's like your comedy is never,
你知道的。更符合维基百科的准确性。但你作为演员的能力就像是——“叹为观止”可能有点夸张了，但我找不到更好的词。我不知道，我不知道。我开玩笑的。但这就像你的喜剧从来不……
your comedy never comes from jokes and you're never making, you know, it's rarely as a pratfall or making faces. It's about your ability to be so convincing with an extremely eccentric character. And yet you can be literally sitting in front of somebody who's super smart and maybe even prime to sort of sniff out some gotcha moments and they still can't tell that it's you, but not even when you're doing those characters, when you're just in films
你的喜剧从来不是靠笑话，你也从来不——你知道的，很少是靠摔跤或做鬼脸。而是关于你能够用一个极其古怪的角色做到如此具有说服力。然而你却可以字面意义上坐在一个超级聪明的人面前，甚至可能准备好去抓你的一些破绽，而他们依然看不出那是你，不仅是在你演这些角色的时候，当你在电影
and dramas and stuff. Like, you didn't take formal training as an actor, did you? I only did one course. I studied with Philippe Gaultier, the legendary clown teacher. Clown, clown school. At l'école Philippe Gaultier. At a clown school. That was it, I did it.
和正剧里演戏的时候也是如此。比如，你没有接受过正规的演员培训，对吧？我只上过一个课程。我跟菲利普·高利耶学习过，那位传奇的小丑老师。小丑，小丑学校。在菲利普·高利耶学校。在小丑学校。就那样，我上了。
But no, I didn't really train in acting, no. It's just something that you tell us. Does it just come natural to you? What do you? Well, I think, yeah, I think, you know, we did an experiment after, in 2016, that show Who's America came out of me and my collaborator, Anne Hines and Dan Swimer,
但没有，我真的没有接受过表演培训，没有。这只是你告诉我们的。这难道不是对你来说很自然吗？你觉得呢？嗯，我想，是的，我想，你知道，我们在2016年之后做了一个实验，那个节目《谁是美国》是我和我的合作者安·海恩斯以及丹·斯维默一起搞出来的，
we basically said, you know what, let's just create some characters. I've done a movie, it'd been a complete bomb, and I was like, let's take this opportunity to create some characters, and we decided to go, every week for the next 10 weeks, we're gonna create a character, write it, create a fake prosthetic head for it,
我们基本上说，你知道吗，我们来创造一些角色吧。我拍过一部电影，结果彻底砸了，我就想，抓住这个机会创造一些角色吧，我们决定，在接下来10周里，每周创造一个角色，写好剧本，为它制作一个假的假体头套，
and at the end of the week, shoot with a real person, with a character. And I did that for 10 weeks, and there were a variety of crazy characters, some that made it to the show. Six we put in the show. And then I realized basically, what I was able to do is,
然后在周末和真人一起拍摄这个角色。我连续10周都这么做，有各种各样疯狂的角色，有些进入了节目。我们把六个放进了节目里。然后我基本上意识到，我能做到的是，
once I've got the way the character speaks and once I work out what it looks like and once I work out what the clothes are and I've got a couple of phrases, I can just stick in it. So that was, because that was a couple of weeks in I was like, oh, this is what I can do is I can, you know, they call it inhabiting a character but I actually kind can, you know, they call it inhabiting a character, but I actually kind of, you know, if I've got 30 seconds or whatever, then I can go in it.
一旦我掌握了角色的说话方式，一旦我弄清楚了它的外表，一旦我弄清楚了服装，并且掌握了几句口头禅，我就可以直接进入状态了。所以这就是，因为过了几个星期后我就想，哦，我能做到的就是，你知道，他们称之为融入角色，但我实际上有点——你知道，他们称之为融入角色，但我实际上有点，你知道，如果我有30秒或者别的什么时间，那么我就可以进入角色。
Probably there must be something wrong with my brain. No, I think some people, it's just comfortable to them to pretend to be somebody else and they just know how to be super subtle and convincing and authentic and it doesn't trip them up and you're able to stay in it. Well, there's a freedom, but there's a freedom too if you think about it, because a lot of those times when you're shooting,
可能我的大脑有点毛病吧。不，我觉得对某些人来说，假装成另一个人是很舒服的事，他们就是知道如何做到超级微妙、有说服力而且真实，这不会难倒他们，而且你能一直保持在角色状态里。嗯，这是一种自由，但如果你仔细想想，这也是一种自由，因为很多时候当你拍戏时，
especially some of the sort of the, whether it's Borat or Brunner or whatever, you've created a character or multiple characters, but the people you're working with are not aware that they're in a scene in the same way, right? So it's much, A, it's difficult because it's complete verite, right? You're actually in their real life, right?
尤其是某种类型的戏，不管是《波拉特》还是布鲁诺还是别的什么，你创造了一个或多个角色，但你合作的人并没有意识到他们是在一个场景里，对吧？所以这非常——A，这很难，因为它是完全的真实电影（Verite），对吧？你实际上是在他们的真实生活中，对吧？
So you've gotta not just convince the audience, you gotta convince the person you're dealing with in the moment that you're real, a real person, right? So you've gotta do that. And there must be a certain, I don't know, like making that leap is tough, I would imagine, like just getting into that. Yeah, what, making it real?
所以你不仅要说服观众，你还得说服你当下打交道的那个人，让他们相信你是真的，是一个真人，对吧？所以你必须做到这一点。而且一定有某种，我不知道，迈出那一步很难，我猜，就是进入那种状态。是的，什么，把它变成真的？
I mean, it's funny, sometimes I get, you know, I'll have a director say, you know, I want you to do a scripted movie, and they'll go, this time you're gonna be playing a real person. Right. And I go, hold on, the other people I play are real people, which is why I'm with Dick Cheney.
我的意思是，这很有趣，有时我会——你知道，会有导演对我说，你知道，我希望你拍一部有剧本的电影，他们会说，这次你要演一个真人。对。我说，等等，我演的其他人也都是真人啊，这就是为什么我和迪克·切尼在一起。
Twice as hard. That's why I'm with Dick Cheney for three hours, and he doesn't doubt once that he's with a real person. What about Giuliani? I mean, thank God, you started that. What can you say? Can you say anything? Can you talk about Giuliani? I mean, thank God, you started that. What can you say? Can you say anything? Can you talk about Giuliani?
难度加倍。这就是为什么我和迪克·切尼在一起呆了三个小时，而他一次都没有怀疑过他是在跟一个真人在一起。那朱利安尼呢？我的意思是，感谢上帝，你挑起了这个话头。你能说什么？你能说点什么吗？你能谈谈朱利安尼吗？我的意思是，感谢上帝，你挑起了这个话头。你能说什么？你能说点什么吗？你能谈谈朱利安尼吗？
Yes, yeah, I can, I think, talk about Giuliani. That was amazing. I mean, essentially, you know, that movie, so we were like, why did we bring Borat back? And actually, I've got to thank Kimmel, where Kimmel said, we want you on, it was like the midterms. And he wanted me to do some sketch where basically
是的，是的，我想我可以谈谈朱利安尼。那太棒了。我的意思是，本质上，你知道，那部电影，所以我们当时在想，我们为什么要把波拉特带回来？其实，我得感谢吉梅尔，吉梅尔当时说，我们想让你上节目，那会儿正好是中期选举。他想让我做一个小品，基本上
I was a kind of Ashton Kutcher type who had been manipulating Kanye West into turning him into a character that was so ridiculous that he would hang out with Donald Trump. And basically I said, I'll do it so long as Kanye will do it. This was years ago. This was 2018, right?
我扮演一个类似阿什顿·库彻那种角色，一直在操纵坎耶·韦斯特，把他变成一个如此荒谬的角色，以至于他会跟唐纳德·特朗普厮混。基本上我说，只要坎耶肯做，我就做。这已经是几年前的事了。这是2018年，对吧？
And so I called up Kanye and said, will you do this thing? And he'd already met up with Trump. And I said, will you do this sketch where it says, we're planning out, we're going to create this ridiculous character. And it's going to end up with you in Trump Tower, and it's going to be as if you were playing along. And he said, I love the idea,
所以我给坎耶打电话说，你愿意做这个东西吗？他当时已经和特朗普见过面了。我说，你愿意做这个小品吗？内容是我们正在策划，我们要创造一个如此荒谬的角色。最后会以你出现在特朗普大厦告终，这就好像你在配合演戏一样。他说，我喜欢这个想法，
but, you know, I need the president to agree. And I was like, Trump? I go, don't, no, no, don't ask him. So, I couldn't do, he goes, no, I love him, and I want you to, I need to ask him. I go, please do not tell him we're doing this sketch at all. So I couldn't do that sketch, and then basically I decided to do Ball Rat.
但是，你知道，我需要总统同意。我就想，特朗普？我说，别，不，不，别去问他。所以，我做不了，他说，不，我喜欢他，我需要你，我需要去问他。我说，请千万别告诉他我们在做这个小品。所以我做不了那个小品，然后基本上我决定做波拉特。
Actually, I spoke to Chris Rock, is that a name drop? I think so, yeah. Sure, we'll pick it up. It's a kind of name drop. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's a name drop. So I spoke to Chris Rock, world famous comedian and actor,
实际上，我跟克里斯·洛克谈过——这是在抛名气吗？我想是的，没错。当然，我们接着说。这算是一种抛名气。对，对，对。这算抛名气。所以我跟克里斯·洛克谈过，世界著名的喜剧演员和演员，
and he said, why don't you, you know, I was in a rush. Basically I was going to go on air two days' time. They said, just do Borat going door to door. We did Borat door to door, got the mustache out of storage, and then I realized that basically ball rap was just an extreme form of Trump. They had almost identical views. Ball rap was kind of 30 to 40% more extreme with everything. I was like, oh great we can bring it back for Trump. And then I was like how do I infiltrate you know Trump's I go, okay, if he has a daughter who's 15,
他说，你为什么不——你知道，我当时很赶。基本上我两天后就要上节目了。他们说，就拍波拉特挨家挨户拜访。我们就拍了波拉特挨家挨户拜访，把假胡子从仓库里拿出来，然后我意识到，基本上波拉特只是特朗普的一个极端化身。他们的观点几乎一模一样。波拉特的每样东西都要极端30%到40%。我就想，太好了，我们可以为了特朗普把它带回来。然后我就想，我怎么才能渗透到，你知道，特朗普的——我心想，好吧，如果他有一个15岁的女儿，
wouldn't it be great if Trump had sex with her? And so, originally I was trying to work out how to get this actress in with Trump. We got a close thing for a while, but it was, we spoke to a lot of ex-Secret Service guys, and the idea was like, I would kind of jump out of the wall somewhere. We had like all these plans where, you know, Trump would be in a room, I would be inside the wall.
如果特朗普和她发生性关系，那不是很好吗？所以，最初我一直在琢磨怎么把这个女演员塞进特朗普那里。我们曾经一度很接近，但是，我们和很多前特勤局的人聊过，这个想法是——我会从某个地方的墙里跳出来。我们有各种计划，比如说，特朗普在一个房间里，我在墙里面。
We would, you know, hollow out a wall, then build it up around me. And then I'd burst out when he was with her. And... Oh, my gosh. An ex-top Secret Service guy looked after with her. And... Oh my gosh. An ex top Secret Service guy looked after the president. And we go, what do you think of this plan? I'm going to be in there. I'll be in there for like five hours.
我们把一面墙掏空，然后在周围建起来。当他和她在一起时，我突然冲出来。然后……我的天哪。一个前高级特勤局人员照顾过总统。我们说，你觉得这个计划怎么样？我要待在里面。我要在里面待大约五个小时。
He said the issue is that Secret Service have a machine that sees if there's anyone else, anyone in the walls. And I go, all right. So I go, what's worse comes worse. They find that I'm there. And what? They pull me out. He goes, no, they shoot you dead. I go, all right, so I go, what's worse comes worse. They find that I'm there. And what, they pull me out. He goes, no, they shoot you dead.
他说问题在于特勤局有一种机器，能看出有没有其他人，有没有人在墙里面。我说，好吧。我说，最坏的情况呢？他们发现我在里面。然后呢？把我拉出来。他说，不，他们会把你开枪打死。我说，好吧，那最坏的情况呢？他们发现我在里面。然后呢，把我拉出来。他说，不，他们会把你开枪打死。
I go, why? He goes, because why else would you be in a, why would there be a living person inside a wall unless they're across the street? I have the assumption that they can't negotiate with a guy like you, they just kill him. So we basically gave up on Trump. Also, you know, we thought at the time
我说，为什么？他说，因为除了你在街对面之外，为什么会有人活在墙里面？我的假设是他们不会跟像你这样的人谈判，他们只会杀了你。所以我们基本上放弃了特朗普。另外，你知道，我们当时认为
that he was the most protected person in the world. I mean, this was prior to those last unfortunate incidents. But Rudy? But then we found out Rudy was a possibility. A little bit of a softer target. Yeah, but we knew that he was going to be crucial. Yeah. And we kind of researched him.
他是世界上受到保护最严密的人。我是说，这是在最近那些不幸事件发生之前。但是鲁迪呢？但后来我们发现鲁迪是有可能的。算是一个稍微软一点的目标。是的，但我们知道他将是至关重要的。是的。我们对他的情况进行了调查。
We found out what he drank, when he started drinking. Was the answer anything? I think there was a particular type of alcohol. But then we heard that he would sweep the room. He had a very senior head of security who would come in and sweep the room. And so we built a kind of fake cupboard inside the wardrobe. So fake back to... There was a wardrobe, if somebody opened it, it would have a fake back to him.
我们查出他喝什么酒，什么时候开始喝酒。答案是什么都有吗？我想有一种特定类型的酒精。但后来我们听说他会搜查房间。他有一个非常高级的安全主管会进来搜查房间。所以我们在衣柜里建了一个假橱柜。作为衣柜的假后壁……有一个衣柜，如果有人打开它，它会有一个假的后壁。
Behind that was me. And so the idea was, you know, I'd just stand in there for, you know, an hour and a half, and then the necessary bit, jump out if he was close to kissing the girl playing my daughter. And anyway, basically, we had a crew member who accidentally put me in the wrong room. And I said, you know, when is, you know,
后面就是我。所以这个想法是，你知道，我只要在里面站上一个半小时，然后在关键时刻，如果他快要亲吻扮演我女儿的那个女孩时，我就跳出来。总之，基本上，我们有一个剧组人员不小心把我放错了房间。我说，你知道，什么时候——你知道，
so I would have to be in position for this to happen. Otherwise, there's no way to get into the room because his head of security would come into the room, sweep the room, sweep every room, and then he would sit outside, so no one could come in with Rudy and her. And I was in the wrong room, and I said, wait a minute, how long till Rudy goes to the room?
所以我必须在指定位置等待这一切发生。否则，根本没有办法进入房间，因为他的安全主管会进入房间，搜查房间，搜查每一个房间，然后他会坐在外面，这样就没有人能跟鲁迪和她一起进来了。而我在错误的房间里，我说，等一下，离鲁迪去那个房间还有多久？
And he said, oh, he's on his way there now. And I was like, now? And basically, I ran to the room. And he said, oh, he's on his way there now. And I was like, now? And basically I ran to the room and I literally saw Rudy's leg come around the corner. I ducked into the room, went into the wardrobe, went behind the fake wall, closed it, and then I heard the door open off his security, sweep the room that I was in, and then come out.
他说，哦，他现在正在去的路上。我说，现在？基本上，我跑向那个房间。他说，哦，他现在正在去的路上。我说，现在？基本上我跑向那个房间，我亲眼看到鲁迪的腿转过拐角。我闪身进了房间，走进衣柜，钻到假墙后面，关上门，然后我听到他的安全人员打开门，搜查了我所在的那个房间，然后出去了。
So he swept to the room. We did the scene, you know, venture... Oh, by the way, so I'm in there for an hour and a half, and you know, the only way I can communicate with the director was through a cell phone. And we thought of everything. I pick up the cell phone, I'm in the pitch black, and there's 3%.
所以他搜查了房间。我们排练了这场戏，你知道，冒险……哦，顺便说一句，我在里面呆了一个半小时，你知道，我与导演沟通的唯一方式是通过手机。我们想到了所有事情。我拿起手机，里面漆黑一片，电量只剩3%。
Oh, wow. An hour and a half. I was like, we did everything. We's 3%. Oh, yeah. You know, now and a half. I was like, we did everything. We've got hidden cameras, we've got the, but we, somebody had not charged the cell phone. So at some point I had to kind of climb out of it and make eye contact with the brilliant actor Maria,
哦，哇。一个半小时。我想，我们什么都做了。电量只剩3%。哦，是的。你知道，一个半小时。我就想，我们什么都做了。我们有隐藏摄像头，我们有这个那个，但是，有人没有给手机充电。所以在某个时刻，我不得不从里面爬出来，与出色的演员玛丽亚进行眼神交流，
who's playing my daughter, and she's like, Rudy's on the bed, and she's like coming out, looking at me and going, what do I do? And eventually I confronted Rudy. He freaks out, goes out the room, and his head of security pushes me into the room. I'm playing Borat, and Borat is so naive. If he sees a chair, he'll say, what is this machine
她扮演我的女儿，而她当时在床上，她走出来，看着我问，我该怎么办？最后我跟鲁迪对质。他吓坏了，跑出房间，他的安全主管把我推进了房间。我演的是波拉特，波拉特是如此天真。如果他看到一把椅子，他会说，这台有四条腿的机器是什么
with four legs? And suddenly, the head of security has pushed me back into the room going, you're going nowhere, because I had an escape route. So my security guy was going to take me down the escape route, but the head of security pushes me into the room and goes, you're going nowhere, you're staying right here. And I said, this is a false imprisonment.
突然之间，安全主管把我推回房间说，你哪儿也别想去，因为我有一条逃生路线。所以我的安保人员本打算带我走逃生路线，但安全主管把我推回房间说，你哪儿也别去，老老实实呆在这儿。我说，这是非法拘禁。
You are standing on my property and you will leave now and unhand me now. And basically he realized that and read the law. Ran down, ran down the fire escape, got into a car, got to the crew hotel, and then essentially my lawyer says, he found out what we did and he said, okay, you've got to get out the state now. I go, that's ridiculous, why? They go, Rudy, Rudy had called something and I'd met the
你正站在我的地盘上，你现在就给我离开，放开我。基本上他意识到了这一点，宣读了法律。我跑下楼，跑下防火梯，钻进一辆车，到了剧组的酒店，然后基本上我的律师说，他发现了我们的所作所为，并说，好吧，你现在必须离开这个州。我说，这太荒谬了，为什么？他们说，鲁迪，鲁迪打过电话，一年后我在华盛顿特区遇到了酒店经理。他说，鲁迪做了一些事。我不知道他打给谁了，但他说是所有的执法人员都涌向了酒店，查封了酒店。
manager of the hotel a year onwards in DC. And he said, Rudy had done something. I don't know what he'd called in, but he said, every single type of law enforcement descended on the hotel, shut down the hotel. They confiscated all the equipment, all the crew was stuck in the hotel rooms. And then my security, I had a policeman that I'd hired, he realized that I'd set up Rudy Giuliani, he immediately told Rudy's security where I lived, where I was staying.
他们没收了所有设备，所有剧组人员都被困在酒店房间里。然后我的安保人员——我雇过一个警察，他意识到我设局陷害了鲁迪·朱利安尼，他立刻把我的住址、我落脚的地方告诉了鲁迪的安保人员。
Jesus Christ. And so my lawyer was like, get the hell out of New York City now. I was like, that seems a little bit over the top. I called up this other security guy I know, I know a lot of security guys, who runs these kind of detectives, you know, New York and stuff like that. I said, listen, I've been told I have to leave New York State, you know, in the next 20 minutes, because I interviewed someone and I go,
天呐。所以我的律师说，马上滚出纽约市。我说，这好像有点小题大做。我给另一个认识的安保人员打电话——我认识很多安保人员，他们负责管理那种侦探业务，你知道，在纽约什么的。我说，听着，我被告知我必须在接下来的20分钟内离开纽约州，因为我采访了某个人，我说，
he goes, what did you do? And I go, you know, more like some lingerie and da-da-da, as a politician. I go, he goes, who was it? I go, it was, you know, Giuliani. He goes, get the hell out of the hotel now. So I start texting everyone who I knew outside of New York, I go, hi, how's it going?
他说，你做了什么？我说，你知道，更像是关于一些内衣和乱七八糟的，作为一个政治家。我说，他问，那是谁？我说，是，你知道，朱利安尼。他说，马上滚出酒店。所以我开始给所有我认识的纽约以外的人发短信，我说，嗨，最近怎么样？
Da-da-da. Haven't seen you for a few years. This was the middle of the pandemic. This is when Manhattan was completely empty. You'd go up Fifth Avenue. There was not a car or a person. I go, how's it going? Any chance I could stay soon.
巴拉巴拉。好几年没见了。当时正处于疫情期间。那是曼哈顿完全空无一人时候。你走到第五大道上。看不到一辆车，也看不到一个人。我说，最近怎么样？有没有可能我去借宿。
When? 15 minutes. And people are like, you know, people are like freaked out, not responding. Eventually one of them says yes and basically I drive to Connecticut and it was fantastic but you got all the footage and you got your equipment all the footage and then yeah it was interesting it was interesting and we will be right back.
什么时候？15分钟后。然后人们就，你知道，人们都吓坏了，不回信息。最后其中一个人答应了，基本上我开车去了康涅狄格州，那太棒了，不过你拿到了所有素材，你拿到了设备，所有素材都有了，然后，是的，这很有趣，这很有趣，我们马上回来。
And now back to the show. So Sasha, I would imagine that the thrill of acting and also the sort of the, and the social relevance, political relevance of some of your efforts is thrilling. Does it compare with the the just the pure acting thrill of being in a film that's directed by Martin Scorsese? I mean, that's just one third of what you're doing when you're doing your other stuff. Can you compare the two of them?
欢迎回到节目。所以萨莎，我想演戏的刺激感，以及你的某些努力所带来的社会相关性、政治相关性，一定很让人兴奋。这跟参演马丁·斯科塞斯导演的电影所带来的纯粹表演上的刺激感相比怎么样？我的意思是，这只是你做其他事情时所付出努力的三分之一。你能把这两者做个比较吗？
Are you drawn towards one versus the other? I mean, I am drawn. I remember the first film I did was Talladega Nights. Yeah, so good. And it was the first trailer I'd been in. Ricky Bobby. And I went in. Ricky Bobby. And basically I remember seeing that there was a bed in the trailer.
你会被其中一方吸引多一点吗？我的意思是，我确实被吸引。我记得我拍的第一部电影是《塔拉迪加之夜》。是的，太棒了。那是我待过的第一个房车。里奇·鲍比。我走了进去。里奇·鲍比。基本上我记得看到房里有一张床。
And I'd never had a trailer beforehand because we'd always been in the back of a car. I was like, why is there a bed? Somebody's accidentally put a bed in my room. They go, no, that's... I go, what am I going to do with it? Sleep, you know. I was like, why is there a bed? Somebody's accidentally put a bed in my room. They go, no, that's, I go, what am I meant to do? Sleep, you know? And so I felt, wow, this is actually an incredible gig. But, you know, when it's the other staff,
我以前从来没有过房车，因为我们总是待在汽车后座上。我就想，为什么会有一张床？有人不小心把一张床放进我的房间了。他们说，不，那是……我说，我拿它怎么办？睡觉呗，你知道的。我当时想，为什么会有一张床？有人不小心放进我房间了。他们说，不，那是，我心想，我该拿它怎么办？睡觉呗，你知道的？所以我觉得，哇，这真的是一份不可思议的工作。但是，你知道，当拍其他那些东西时，
it is, I mean, it's much less stressful. Although, you know, I just did a, I just did this show with Alfonso Cuaron. Yes, let's talk about that. That's coming up on Apple. Well, we had like a 15 minute scene, yeah, with me and Cate Blanchett, they wanted to do in one take. And that became pretty exhausting and pretty...
那是——我的意思是，压力要小得多。虽然，你知道，我刚拍了——我刚跟阿方索·卡隆合作了这部剧。是的，我们聊聊这个。即将在Apple上播出的那部。嗯，我们有一场大约15分钟的戏，是的，我和凯特·布兰切特，他们想要一镜到底。那变得相当累人，而且相当……
Do you have a passion for acting, like the fricking craft of acting? Yes, I mean, if it's good, and you're working with an incredible director, then, and you're an incredible director, my friend. I love you so much. No, you are. Can I just say, let's do the remainder of this
你对表演有热情吗，比如表演这门该死的手艺？是的，我的意思是，如果剧本好，你又和一位不可思议的导演合作，那么，你就是一位不可思议的导演，我的朋友。我太爱你了。不，你真的是。我能说，我们把剩下的时间
about Jason Bay. But yeah, then it is great. But it's in different categories for you, though, yes? I mean, it's not comparable, right? They're different things, yes? No, no, because you're just doing the act. Everything else is how are we going to get into the room? What's the escape route?
都用来聊杰森·贝特曼吧。但是，是的，那真的很棒。但对你来说，这是不同的范畴吧？我的意思是，这不具可比性，对吧？它们是不同的东西，对吗？不，不，因为你只是在表演。其他所有事情都是：我们怎么才能混进房间？逃生路线是什么？
Who's that person? That person's looking suspicious. This person doesn't quite believe me. My fake ear is falling off my head. And then your number eight in the thing is I put an act to sing. Yeah, yeah. Now, Sajar, I speak on behalf of millions of people
那个人是谁？那个人看起来很可疑。这个人不太相信我。我的假耳朵从头上掉下来了。然后你的第八个要点是我在演戏。对，对。现在，萨莎，我代表千百万
that are fans of yours, like I am, like huge fans where we're constantly waiting for your next thing, because you're one of the few artists that combine art and politics and have been so successful in all of those improvisational types of whatever you call them, movies where you play these characters. Obviously you can't tell us if you're,
喜欢你的粉丝说话，就像我一样，庞大的粉丝群体，我们一直在期待你的下一个作品，因为你是少数几个将艺术与政治结合起来的艺术家之一，并且在所有那些即兴形式的——无论你怎么称呼它们——你扮演这些角色的电影中都取得了巨大成功。显然你不能告诉我们，
what it is you're working on, but are you, could we expect another character to pop up in a movie soon? Are you excited about that type of thing to do that again? Because from the outside, I can't wait. Short of the straight acting thing with Kate Blanchett. excited about that type of thing to do that again? Because from the outside, I can't wait. I can't wait for those types of things again. The last one became so extreme.
你在忙些什么，但我们会很快期待另一个角色出现在电影里吗？你对做那种类型的事情、再次尝试感到兴奋吗？因为从局外人的角度来看，我等不及了。除了与凯特·布兰切特的纯正演技合作之外。对那种事情、再次尝试感到兴奋吗？因为从局外人的角度来看，我等不及了。我等不及再次看到那些类型的作品了。上一次变得太极端了。
After that gun rally thing that I was talking about, I was essentially on the run, I had a militia kind of following me, and we were going, I was going from safe house to safe house for about four days. That's the movie. Yeah, exactly. By the way, I mean, it's... That was, yeah, it kind of is the movie, because, you know, you finish that song with that militia, you go, oh, that went really well, And then, you know, the escape itself is tough because we're in an ambulance,
在我谈到的那场持枪集会之后，我基本上是在逃亡，有一群民兵在追踪我，我大概花了四天时间从一个安全屋辗转到另一个安全屋。这就是电影。是的，恰恰如此。顺便说一句，我的意思是，它……那，是的，这某种程度上就是电影，因为，你知道，你和那群民兵结束了拍摄，你想，哦，那进展得真顺利，然后，你知道，逃跑本身就很艰难，因为我们坐在一辆救护车里，
we're surrounded by 30 guys trying to pull me out of the ambulance, they pull open the door. You know, I'm struggling. But we can't get enough of that. We can't get enough of that. Yeah, I mean, no one's rec... You know, that's the behind the scenes stuff that, at some point, there needs to be a behind the scenes movie.
我们被30个人包围，他们试图把我从救护车里拉出来，他们拉开车门。你知道，我在挣扎。但我们看不够。我们看不够。是的，我的意思是，没有人记录……你知道，那是幕后花絮，在某个时刻，需要有一部幕后花絮电影。
We shot, we did have, we've got a bunch of footage over the last 25 years, but yeah, that, I think it became so crazy in the last one that you realize you've, you know, you've gotta be, there's a certain amount of skill and preparation about always gonna be lucky, and at some point, your luck runs out. Your luck runs out.
我们拍了，我们确实有，我们在过去25年里收集了大量素材，但是，是的，那一次，我觉得上一次太疯狂了，你意识到你必须——你知道，必须具备一定的技巧和准备，你总会走运，但在某个时刻，你的好运就会用光。你的好运会用光。
And then just the practicality of it, because it has been so successful for so long, this type of, again, for lack of a better term, ambush type of thing. Like people know you. They love these films. Millions and millions of people have seen them. You just can't sneak up on anybody anymore.
然后就是它的现实操作性，因为它已经成功了这么久，这种，再次找不到更好的词来形容，伏击式的类型。就像人们认识你一样。他们喜欢这些电影。千千万万的人看过它们。你再也无法悄悄接近任何人了。
Yes. Well, I think just the danger element meant that I just didn't really want to do it again. You know, I had to do it for that election. I had to do it. I felt it was like, you know, I was terrified about what's going to happen. Well, let's not come off the gas just yet, okay? Yes.
是的。嗯，我想仅仅是危险的元素就意味着我真的不想再这样做了。你知道，为了那场选举我不得不这么做。我必须去做。我觉得这就好像，你知道，我对将要发生的事情感到恐惧。好吧，我们可别现在就松油门，好吗？好的。
We're not out of the woods yet, Sasha. Still need you. That's true. You know, I haven't asked you one fucking question and we're done. You have. We're finished with the time. No, I've got all these things all like highlighted and everything.
我们还没脱离危险呢，萨莎。我们还需要你。确实如此。你知道的，我连一个特么的问题都还没问呢，我们就结束了。你问了。我们的时间到了。不，我把这些东西全都做好了高亮标记什么的。
It's, I apologize to the listener. We haven't done any legitimate journalism here. Let's at least talk about disclaimer and working with Alfonso Cuaron and Apple and Kate Blanchett. I mean, it's well, well, well deserved for your acting talents to be working with these people at the top of the profession.
这是，我对听众感到抱歉。我们这里没有做任何合法的采访。我们至少应该谈谈《免责声明》以及与阿方索·卡隆、Apple和凯特·布兰切特的合作。我的意思是，你的演艺才华能够与这些行业顶尖人物合作，真的是实至名归。
So have you seen it all the way through, disclaimer? I watched it for the first time in Venice. Yeah. And I mean, no one could believe that I hadn't watched it for the first time in Venice. And no one could believe that I hadn't watched it until then. The embarrassing thing was I was laughing at the jokes that I'm making. There's not many, but it's quite embarrassing. You're at Premiere watching yourself and you're one of the only people laughing at jokes.
所以你看完整部剧了吗，《免责声明》？我第一次看是在威尼斯。是的。我的意思是，没有人相信我之前没在威尼斯第一次看过。没有人相信直到那时我才看过。尴尬的是，我居然在笑自己开的玩笑。虽然没几个笑话，但还是挺尴尬的。你在首映式上看自己的作品，而你是唯一几个在笑话处笑出声的人之一。
And then I was really moved by one of my performances. I was like near-tear. And I realized I'm just a complete narcissist. Just looking, just really moved by my own performance. Wait, it wasn't until Venice this year that you realized that? Wow. I never knew there was a connection between actors in movies and narcissism.
然后我真的被自己的其中一段表演打动了。我差点流泪。然后我意识到我完全是个自恋狂。只是在看着，真的被自己的表演感动了。等等，直到今年威尼斯电影节你才意识到这一点吗？哇。我从来不知道电影演员和自恋之间有什么联系。
No, I love it. I'll bet it's absolutely stunning. It's a... It's actually excellent. between actors in movies and narcissism. No, I love that. I'll bet it's absolutely stunning. It's actually excellent. It comes out October. Or it came out. When does it came out? When is it?
不，我喜欢这样。我敢打赌它绝对惊艳。这是一部——其实真的很棒。电影演员和自恋之间有什么联系。不，我喜欢这样。我敢打赌它绝对惊艳。其实真的很棒。十月上映。或者说已经上映了。什么时候上映的？是什么时候？
When's this coming out? October 11th. When's this coming out? Yeah, it came out. It came out October 11th. Yeah. It came out October 11th. It was amazing.
这到底什么时候上映？10月11日。这什么时候上映？对，它上映了。10月11日上映的。是的。10月11日上映的。这太棒了。
It's incredible. No, I mean, October 11th, the weather was so great that day. Did you know I loved it? It was great. It was fantastic. Sasha, when do we get to, will you be coming back to Los Angeles at any time soon and we can all hang out again?
太不可思议了。不，我是说，10月11日那天天气真好。你知道我有多喜欢吗？太棒了。太精彩了。萨莎，我们什么时候能——你最近会回洛杉矶吗？这样我们大家又能聚在一起了。
Yes, I will. I'd love to see you. Like the old days. God damn it, I love seeing you. And Sean, it'd be lovely to meet you in the flesh. I would love that too. I'm around, just give a shout. If you need a place to crash
会的，我会的。我很想见你们。就像旧时光一样。该死的，我真喜欢见你们。还有肖恩，很高兴能见到真人。我也很想。我就在附近，打个招呼就行。如果你需要落脚的地方，
when you're in trouble in New York again, my place is yours. Great. If you don't mind my militias coming to your door. Yeah. No, are you kidding? What do they look like? You were really, really nice to say yes to this. I know you don't do this a lot. Yeah. No, no, no. I'm awful at it.
当你在纽约又惹麻烦的时候，我的地方就是你的。太好了。如果你不介意我的民兵朋友去你家敲门的话。好吧。不，你在开玩笑吧？他们长什么样？你答应得真是太好了，太友好了。我知道你平时不怎么做这个。是的。不，不，不。我在这方面糟透了。
The honest truth is I'm very bad at it. Are you kidding? Even though I see you socially. Socially, it's a pleasure, but the slight pressure with the... No pressure. No, this is great. This is fantastic.
老实说，我在这方面非常差劲。你在开玩笑吧？尽管我们在社交场合经常见面。在社交场合这是一种乐趣，但带着这种微小的压力——没有压力。不，这很棒。这太精彩了。
You're a world-class... Very muscly. I can see your... I don't know if you're doing this intentionally, but I've seen glutes. Oh, thanks. It's got everything. No, you've been working out, looking very...
你是一个世界级的——肌肉非常发达。我能看到你的……我不知道你是不是故意的，但我看到臀肌了。哦，谢谢。应有尽有。不，你一直在锻炼，看起来非常……
Put your arms down. Are you doing this for a reason? This is from my pinup collection. Early short. I think this was my July from my calendar. Wow. Wow, you really actually do look incredible. Prison with Arnett, that's the calendar.
把你的胳膊放下。你这么做是有原因的吗？这是我的海报收藏。早期的短片。我想这是我的日历上的七月。哇。哇，你实际上看起来真的很不可思议。与阿内特同囚，这就是那个日历。
Sasha, thank you so, so, so much. No, thank you. We love you a lot. Please come out to LA and say hi. I love you, no, seriously, so, so much. No, thank you. We love you a lot. Please come out to LA and say hi. I love you. No, seriously, I love you both. Sean, you seem very lovely. He's the best of the three of us.
萨莎，非常非常感谢你。不，谢谢你们。我们非常爱你。请一定要来洛杉矶打个招呼。我爱你，不，说真的，非常非常感谢。不，谢谢你们。我们非常爱你。请一定要来洛杉矶打个招呼。我爱你。不，说真的，我爱你们俩。肖恩，你看起来非常可爱。在我们三个中间他是最好的。
Miss you, Sasha. Always a pleasure. These two I do love, I do love. We're trash compared to him. Where do you get a love in him? I love you, Sasha. Even though we don't know each other, I love you. You love me.
想你，萨莎。总是这么愉快。这俩我是真的爱，我是真的爱。跟比他比起来我们就是垃圾。你从哪儿学来对他的这种爱？我爱你，萨莎。尽管我们不认识，我爱你。你爱我。
I feel affectionate. I feel an instant warmth. Oh, he's a little love thing. You love me. I feel affectionate, I feel an instant warmth. Oh, he's a little love thing. Yeah, yeah, very charming and lovely persona. You just want to pet him when you see him. He totally does seem like that, you're right. You're not going to sue me for saying that, are you? Okay.
我感到充满爱意。我感受到一种即时的温暖。哦，他是个小可爱。你爱我。我感到充满爱意，我感受到一种即时的温暖。哦，他是个小可爱。是的，是的，非常迷人且可爱的形象。你看到他就想去抚摸他。他完全就是那种人，你说得对。你不会因为我这么说而起诉我吧？好吧。
Okay. Kay Monte Strong on our podcast. Loved it. Thank you, buddy. Thank you and goodbye. Enjoy the rest of your night. Thank you. No, thank you, Ferg.
好吧。凯·蒙特·斯特朗在我们的播客上。太喜欢了。谢谢你，老兄。谢谢你，再见。享受剩下的夜晚吧。谢谢。不，谢谢你，弗格。
I can't wait for Disclaimer. Everybody check it out on Apple. Honestly, I would say I thought it was excellent. Yeah, we'll see you at the Emmys on that. I was clever. I hope they put, they should put that on the poster I think it's excellent Personally thought it was excellent. I have seen stuff that I've done. I was like that is bad I loved it and I cried at myself
我等不及要看《免责声明》了。大家快去Apple上看吧。说实话，我觉得它太棒了。对，我们在艾美奖上见吧。我太机智了。我希望他们把这个放海报上，我觉得它太棒了。我个人觉得太棒了。我看到自己演的东西时曾想：那太烂了。但我很喜欢，而且我为自己感动得哭了。
But it'd be pretty fucking funny to have a quote from one of the stars of the film He's all of them k-blond shit. Okay, Blanchett a guaranteed from one of the stars of the film. All of them. Cate Blanchett. Cate Blanchett. A guaranteed Emmy, two out of four. Cate Blanchett. End of quote. He's fucking great. Kevin Kline.
不过，如果能引述电影主演的话，那特么会非常搞笑。他们所有人，凯特·布兰切特。凯特·布兰切特。电影主演的必看引言。所有人。凯特·布兰切特。凯特·布兰切特。保底一个艾美奖，四分之二。凯特·布兰切特。引言结束。他太特么棒了。凯文·克莱恩。
I am in this. Oh, Kevin Kline's in it too? Kevin Kline's in it. He's actually fantastic in it. I love Kevin Kline. I love him. I'd like to see more from him. All right, enjoy the rest of your night.
我也演了这部的。哦，凯文·克莱恩也在里面？凯文·克莱恩也在。他在里面其实棒极了。我喜欢凯文·克莱恩。我爱死他了。我很想看到他更多的作品。好了，享受剩下的夜晚吧。
All right. Thank you. See you soon. Love to everyone. OK, toodaloo, thank you, bye. Thank you, pal. Bye, pal. Bye, bye. That's a great guest, Jay, that was really, really great.
好的。谢谢。回头见。代问大家好。好啦，拜拜，谢谢，再见。谢谢你，老伙计。再见，老伙计。拜拜。真是个棒极了的嘉宾，杰，刚才真的太棒了。
Sasha, yeah, great job, JB. I just love him. Sasha Baron Cohen, he's fucking funny. He's got great stories. One of the funniest guys, I mean, he's up there with Sean Hayes, Will Arnett, and Will Ferrell in my world. I just like, they just can't, I get in an instant good mood
萨莎，是的，干得漂亮，JB。我太喜欢他了。萨莎·拜伦·科恩，他特么太搞笑了。他有好多精彩的故事。最搞笑的家伙之一，我的意思是，在我看来，他跟肖恩·海斯、威尔·阿内特和威尔·法瑞尔不相上下。我就是觉得，他们就是无法——当我跟这些人在一起时，我会立刻进入好心情。
when I'm with these people. Well, nobody, I was gonna say to him, nobody does, I mean, it sounds so cliche to say it, but it's true, nobody does what he does. Nobody's ever done what he does. No one's got the intelligence, the balls, or the acting talent to do what he does. Yeah, it's like a Peter Sellers.
嗯，没有人——我刚想对他说，没有人——这话说出来听起来太老套了，但这是真的，没有人做他做的事。从来没有人做过他做的事。没有人有他那样的智气、胆量或演技来做他做的事。是的，就像彼得·塞勒斯。
Which is his hero, by the way. We didn't even get into that. Oh, really? I'm sure. Yeah, that's his idol. It's like a version of that in real life when he goes. But I'm applying it to the real world. Yeah, that's what I'm saying. Right, which is so, yeah.
顺便说一句，这也是他的偶像。我们甚至都没聊到这个。哦，真的吗？我敢肯定。是的，那是他的偶像。就像是现实生活中的那种版本，当他去——但我把它应用到现实世界中。是的，这就是我要说的。对，所以，是的。
It's really cool. I never met him before. He just seems so, I'd love to hang out with him. Yeah. He'd like the greatest at a party. I just start to hover and he's eventually got to walk away from me because I just put in too much time. He seems hyper intelligent.
这真的很酷。我以前没见过他。他看起来就是那种——我很想跟他一起玩。是的。他在派对上绝对是最棒的。我只会开始在旁边晃悠，然后他最后不得不走开，因为我在他身上花的时间太多了。他看起来智商超级高。
He is. Oh yeah, Cambridge educated. Oh wow, yeah of course. Not a ding dong. Speaking of ding dongs, what's for lunch today, Sean? We're gonna do a French dip. And with French fries. Why is it always something special?
他是。哦，对，剑桥毕业的。哦，哇，对，当然。不是个笨蛋。说到笨蛋，肖恩，今天午饭吃什么？我们要吃法式蘸面包三明治。还有炸薯条。为什么总是有什么特别的？
Like it's always got something with sauce or like some kind of like really electric flavor to it. How about just like some sort of sustenance? Aren't you amazed at how fast I know my answers whenever you ask what I had or what I'm going to have? Well, we're cutting into it right now, right? You can probably smell it, right? Where is it?
就像它总是带着酱汁或者某种非常带劲的风味。来点能维持体力的东西怎么样？每当你问我吃了什么或者打算吃什么时，你不觉得我对答如流的速度很惊人吗？我们现在正切开它，对吧？你可能闻得到了，对吧？它在哪？
It's two o'clock in the East Coast. You can probably smell it. Yeah. Is it already? It's just waiting on the table. Where is it from? No, I'm going to, the second I, there's a place, a block away,
东海岸现在两点。你大概能闻到它。对。已经好了吗？它就在桌上等著呢。它是哪买的？不，我打算，我一，有个地方，就在一个街区外，
I can't remember the name of it. Don't say the name, someone will try to poison you. Yeah, no. I can't remember, but it, a block away, I can't remember the name of it. Don't say the name, someone will try to poison you. Yeah, no, I can't remember, but it's a block away. It only takes a second to get, yeah. It's so good. Wow. It's so good. It's one of the best in the city. You know what I'm gonna have?
我想不起它的名字了。别说名字，免得有人想毒死你。对，不。我想不起来了，但是，就在一个街区外，我想不起名字了。别说名字，免得有人想毒死你。对，不，我想不起来了，但它就在一个街区外。拿过来只要一会儿，对。太好吃了。哇。太好吃了。这是全城最好的之一。你知道我要吃什么吗？
What? Nothing. Yeah. Because I have, because I've got this stupid level of discipline about, because of my passion for my character, my strong- I get it, I know you do. I know you're joking, but it's true, and it's very admirable. And-
什么？没有。对。因为我，因为我对这事有着愚蠢的纪律感，因为我对角色的热情，我那强烈的——我懂，我知道你懂。我知道你在开玩笑，但这确实是真的，而且非常令人钦佩。而且——
I'm so tired. It's not a healthy way to do it. I know, I'm tired of being thin. But Wednesday, that's what I'm saying, Wednesday after Wednesday is over, and you wrap your beautiful show, an amazing show that everybody's gonna go ape shit about. Yeah, Thursday, no, Wednesday or Thursday, no.
我太累了。这不是一种健康的做法。我知道，我厌倦了保持苗条。但周三，这就是我说的，周三结束之后，等你完成了你那部精彩的剧集，一部会让所有人疯狂的精彩剧集。对，周四，不，周三还是周四，不。
Yeah, Wednesday wrap, so Thursday our dinner, can it be something super fattening? Yeah. I have to have, so I'm not, because I have lost weight, I'm on a new thing which is it's all about eating more and eating the right thing, and that's what I'm talking about, losing weight unhealthily is not good. You can lose weight and also do it in a healthy way
对，周三杀青，所以周四我们的晚餐，能吃点热量超高的东西吗？可以。我得吃，为了不，因为我已经瘦了，我开始了一种新方法，核心就是多吃并且吃对东西，这就是我所说的，不健康地减肥是不好的。你既能减肥又能用健康的方式
and look like this or like that. How you doing? So then what am I gonna have Thursday night? Am I gonna have steak? You know, is steak okay? Yeah, a lot of steak and veggies, no starch, no bread, no nothing like that. Why can't you do pizza?
而且长成这样或那样。你最近怎么样？那我周四晚上要吃什么？我要吃牛排吗？你知道，吃牛排可以吗？可以，很多牛排和蔬菜，没有淀粉，没有面包，什么都没有。为什么你不能吃披萨？
Can you do pizza? You can have a little bit, no. No. No, man. A little bit of starch at lunch, a tiny bit, like a little bit of maybe a sweet potato, a couple bit, like a little bit of maybe a sweet potato, a couple pieces, maybe a little bit of rice like that much. Yeah.
你能吃披萨吗？你能吃一点点，不行。不行。不行，老兄。午餐可以有一点点淀粉，极少的一点，比如一点点红薯，几块，可能一点点红薯，几块，可能一点点米饭，就那么多。对。
A couple, yeah. You gotta release the valve every once in a while. So you want a little tiny little bite of pizza, Sean. One sheet meal a week, one meal. To keep your metabolic rate going, right? Yeah, one. But it's not about, here's the other thing. It's not fast metabolism or slow metabolism, it turns out.
几块，对。你偶尔得释放一下压力。所以你想吃一小口披萨，肖恩。一周放纵一餐，就一餐。为了保持你的新陈代谢率，对吧？对，一餐。但这不是关于，还有另一件事。事实证明，这跟新陈代谢快慢无关。
Hot or cold. And what you need to do to keep your metabolism hot is you need to feed it with the right stuff at the right time of day. I went and saw this guy, unbelievable. Unreal. And he did, we did a blood test. Is it a guy you're dating?
是热还是冷。你需要做的是让新陈代谢保持活跃，你需要在一天中合适的时间给它提供合适的东西。我去找了这个人，难以置信。太不真实了。他做了，我们做了一个血检。这人是你约会对象吗？
Oh, a nutritionist. We're just seeing each other. He, I mean, I met him right behind, you know the party store on Sunset. Sure. So I'm like, and I hear, shh. He says, I'm going to be in a Corolla. And he, no, anyway.
哦，一个营养师。我们只是在交往。他，我是说，我遇到他的地方就在，你知道日落大道那个派对商店后面。当然。所以我说，我听到，嘘。他说，我会开一辆花冠。然后他，不，总之。
How many times did he flash the brights? What was the code? Well, it was Morris Code, and I thought he said, help, and it was, can you help me with my pants? He was just a person. He was like a bystander? Bystander? We'll just commit to it. Just do that. Someone's hungry. Try to do it without going up on by this time.
他闪了几次远光灯？暗号是什么？嗯，那是莫尔斯电码，我以为他说的是“救命”，结果是“你能帮我弄一下裤子吗”。他只是个路人？路人？我们就接受这个设定吧。就这么演。有人饿了。争取在被这个绊倒之前搞定。
Okay? So the guy... I know that guy you met behind the party. He was just a regular bystander. Yeah, not as good, but... By! By! Byeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry and Rob Armjarff. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好吗？所以那家伙……我认识你在派对后面遇到的那个家伙。他只是个普通的局外人。对，没那么好，但是……拜！拜！拜eeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee。SmartList由Bennett Barbico、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Armjarff 100%手工有机制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。